e
oh it it will
right okay good morning everybody we
have a 9 o'clock uh hearing schedule for
today so I'd like to welcome everybody
to a new Monday um I'd like to just
Express a couple observations I just
observed from March
Madness
and you know we can learn a lot from
what's going on in March Madness and I'd
like to reflect on on a team that we've
never heard anything about it's Long
Beach State out in
California and this particular
team had a problem towards the end of
the season and their coach is coach
Monson m o n s o n
and I was listening to a and reading a
column by Andrew Beaton On The Wall
Street Journal early this morning he's
the one that covers their Athletics and
in this article he was talking about Mr
Monson and what's he's done out there at
Long Beach
State prior to the tournament and
they're in the big West we have the Big
East with St John's and Providence and
Yukon etc etc Georgetown well they have
the big
West and prior to their tournament that
conference
Championship they lost their big the
biggest the person that's usually in the
center the big tall one that getting
hammered all the time like my grandson
got hammered playing he's the big for St
Lawrence he played with a bum ankle
during that game also got a broken nose
during that game the final game in the
in the finals there in that Liberty
league but going back to the big big
West prior to that they lost their big
for the five consecutive games prior to
the conference Championship and lost all
five
games the athletic director out at they
call it Beach Long Beach okay at beach
um came up to the coach and said we want
you to retire well you're done he said
please let me play through the
conference Championship with my kids and
he said no you're going to have to
retire and he says no I won't
retire and so he played the
championship in the big West they won
the first game the second game and the
third game and took the
championship and what they are now
they're the 15th seed into the
NCAA uh March Madness right now yeah
they have to play Arizona the second
seed but that is a miracle what happened
there and we talk often times about the
Cinderella teams I think Cinderella
already occurred and you know I'll be
I'll be on Thursday if we're in session
Rick lad will be looking at that game
when we're in session because I'm really
excited to see something like that and
looking at coach Monson you just wonder
what's so special about
him he's been with Long Beach for 17
years prior to that he was pulled by
Minnesota and Minnesota was having a
real problem with their athletes and
academics he cleaned that up but the
most important thing to look at in his
career should go back to
1999 and and he was one that brought in
a real small College into the uh March
Madness that small College was called
Gonzaga and he took him to the elite
elite 8 in his first season with Gonzaga
and so this man is really and what the
kids said to him before they went into
this championship in their conference
League he they said to him Coach don't
worry we got you back and they came
together and they did it so that's what
you know what a good coach and a good
teacher can do and and uh I hope we you
know can just watch a little bit of that
and see what happens I'm going to hand
the gavl over right now and give it to
uh represent before start
yeah thank you Mr chair I have forwarded
to the committee a front page article on
Art
Ellison you may recall art has not been
here this year uh he is now in hospice
and he's been hospice for uh about three
weeks now and uh so the uh the article I
think uh captures his Spirit uh and his
priorities as a legislator and as a
human being and I think the article is
is well worth reading and uh several of
us have been visiting art arm on a daily
basis just to check in with him so uh we
just wanted to give you an update on
that thank you Mr chairman oh thank you
very much and we're all thinking of art
art has a lot of experience in education
he worked for with doe he has
contributed to this committee for years
and you know we're we're we're thinking
of him thank you very much for your
comments okay I'm going to hand the gavl
amendment uh thank you Mr chairman
welcome everybody um and we have uh
several substitutes I think uh today
coming in one is here right now
represent Cel um is sitting in for
um uh oh represent of Woodcock I believe
we
switched
okay okay
yeah okay um and um I emailed you the uh
switch the um
substitutes uh hearing on House Bill
1450 um and uh I will call on
representative L to uh discuss his
Amendment thank you very much Mr chair
and members of the education committee
uh for the record my name is Rick lad I
come from hail and I'm here today to
speak to hb1 1450 we have a non- gerain
Amendment and I let me explain why it is
non-
gerain back when we established or the
governor established the uh go by
executive order the task force for
looking at uh higher education and where
we're going in the future present and
future with higher education we
simultaneously put forward HB
1450 and or
1450 was a a a bill which had very very
similar type language within it however
the title of that bill was very contrary
or different to that of uh the executive
order and what we did is in the title of
that bill it talked about consolidating
higher education other words we have two
systems who was talking about
consolidation and consolidation was
taken many many different ways and as as
I mentioned to you uh when I introduced
1450 originally consolidation as I saw
was trying to merge different programs
together between campuses it was not
aimed at that word that some are not
wanting spoken merger that's not what we
were talking about but what we have now
before us is an amendment which is the
whole bill and it's been declared non-
gerine by the speaker and the the house
clerk doe to the fact we're changing
statutory reference from 188j to
1898 um 7 a that's one part but the
title of the bill has also been changed
I'll read the title here so you can see
that the word consolidation it's not
there requiring the university system of
New Hampshire and the community college
system of New Hampshire to further work
toward implementing comprehensive higher
education alignment strategies and
findings identified in the governor's
public higher education task force
report so the governor's task force
report has been we've been working on
Fridays I'm kind of getting burned out
on Fridays and but we've been doing this
for I don't know how long Mr Apple be 10
weeks 10 weeks and it's been you know
constant that and and when we didn't
didn't get one on on on higher education
of course the trustees decide to have
their meeting on the same Friday so it's
been just full boore and what we've done
through that is we've looked at where we
are with higher education today and what
we need to have to do to align
strategies and develop these findings to
bring some of these efficiencies into
our system to to address some of the
issues that we hear spoken to in our
public and amongst
ourselves so some of the changes which
we see there you can see there's a
change in the act itself the title
that's
important we we can't stand still and
watch our demographic in the state slide
down from 210,000 students when I came
on board here to now roughly 154 to
160,000 K through2 students that means
we're feeding fewer students we have
fewer population moving in that's not
just similar to New Hampshire but it's
it's similar to all New England states
and in fact our country so we're all
challenged to draw these students to our
University system and I want to make
sure that everybody's aware that the
university system right now and the
community college system are wonderful
wonderful institutions when you look at
the three uh four-year systems we have
UNH has an exemplary research program
when you look at Keen there's a
wonderful education preparation program
there and and getting some of the
theater areas and and the music programs
which they have exceptional and when you
get to the cluster program which
Plymouth state has and dealing with the
community and their teacher programs and
their business programs they have a
wonderful program and staff that is
really working as Mr Monson works with
his coaches and that's the way I see it
in these schools the community college
system is equal in providing that
Regional services that are NE necessary
in the state to a bring in affordability
the Dual con concurrent enrollment
program is an exceptional program which
has led to that but also what those uh
schools are doing in terms of trying to
get the not the traditional young 18 19
year old student but they're drafting in
the students are coming back for career
change and Workforce need to meet
Workforce needs that are oft times in
their mid 20s 30s 40s and I'm sure that
the chanc behind me can say there's some
even higher than that in age uh that are
retooling so looking at the amendment
itself the non- gerain amendment the on
line 17 the university system New
Hampshire and Community College system
shall in accordance with findings
identified in the public higher
education task force report develop and
Implement systemwide higher education
alignment strategies too doe a through
uh F there those strategies were in the
uh Governor's executive report so that's
not changed at all we did add in a g
that's on line 28 and that simply says
continue collaborative work establishing
curricular Pathways for transfer a
program and a degree credit amongst the
2-year and four-year systems that's
hp53 and that is we're we're not saying
we're there yet we've heard testimony
come in from our provos saying yes we
have 30 uh uh degree programs were
were're aligning between but we haven't
got there with all of them yet yet and
but we're working towards that and we
should have that work all completed by
uh June 30 of of this of this year but
we don't want to leave it at that so we
put that in this report turning to the
sheet we're looking at what we want the
the the higher education uh task force
uh was also setting up a commission a
commission and we know that a commission
wouldn't go in effect until a commission
to oversee this the commission wouldn't
go in effect until at least July 1 or
when this is signed in the law we
already have a higher education study
committee made up of senators and
representatives with that task if you
look into our statutes they have the
responsibility doing exactly what that
commission would do we don't need to
establish another
commission so we are advocating that
there be a oversight committee and that
oversight committee will receive
quarterly reports it's like a a a flight
path where we're going from where we are
to where we want to go and there are
quarterly reports due along that flight
path each year and with an annual report
that's also due so there is going to be
open communication between where what's
going on now who's going to be doing the
what's going on the report stipulates
that we are going to be handing to them
uh I also want to look at you know you
have at the bottom I I think of of of
the sheet that I handed out to you the
members of the governor's higher
education task
force look down through those names and
you can see folks that are from the
business industry Association you see
them from doe you can see them from the
Department of Employment Security the
Deputy Commissioner you can see the
chancellors of both the the uh
University system and the community
college system you can see Senator gray
on it myself on it representative luno
on it you can see Nick thus who has been
HHS commissioner and also with the
community college system Ed Smith uh
also with the college system George
Hansel is from the trustees of the uh
University system New Hampshire
and Jackie Eastwood who's always a kick
she's also on the trustee board uh from
the University system and very much into
business and small business uh and
George Hansel also being small business
oriented so that group coming together
and I feel honored to been a part of
that I you know I'm looking at these
people that have all this wisdom and all
this understanding where we need to go
and respond to so higher education can
be responding to the everchanging needs
of our Workforce and of the economy and
of making education affordable for
students and that's one of the drivers
of this report we know that uh we cannot
continue charging what we're charging
for Education it's it's hard for our New
Hampshire kids it really is to come up
with that and come out with all this
huge debt and that's been an issue of
discussion amongst group so we have this
draft draft report right here and I want
to caution this is draft it hasn't been
uh final we meet again this Friday yeah
this Friday and possibly the Friday
after that to try and bring some closure
to this um I I feel that this is a
wonderful report we're not getting down
and mentioning what's in that report in
this bill that's not what it's all about
we have tasked in the uh uh uh non-gain
Amendment here it's the responsibility
of the two chancellors to work
collaboratively together and look at how
these efficiencies can occur we've
already heard discussion regarding that
of the idea of of merging or putting
administrative uh leadership in a
location a single colocation where you
have now people working together not
duplicating Services where you might
have the university system hanging out
at nhti now and University system
hanging out at the other end down by the
shopping mall they're going to be
together working cooperatively together
we need those efficiencies and those
efficiencies have already started and
some of the specifics that are they are
driving at I'm sure will be spoken at to
when others come up to speak so in
conclusion I'd like to recommend that we
move this forward there there may be
some other additions to this amendment
when it gets to the Senate Side based
upon the findings and recommendations
that come out of this report uh but this
is something where there needs to be a
uh a oversight type group looking at
what's going on keeping people on task
making sure reports are done making sure
change occurs and that's the going to be
the responsibility as it stands right
now the high education study committee
so I'd be glad to take any any questions
from the
committee thank you representative
representative Miler thank you Mr
chair as I look at your a through G here
um representing
lad and you'd mentioned earlier
the question of student
debt is there a reason why that was not
the the specific issue of student debt
was not part of the aggregate here that
G um I I I understand that that these
are meant to streamline cost for the
institution
Etc but we this committee has has also
had a bill before us earlier that talked
about student debt so I was just it's
just a question of why that wasn't
highlighted as part of the uh a a
through G there's a lot of reasons why
in see the optim optimizing access for
students that's part of it but we've
also identified other issues which are
relative to that and I think you you
might get a better response uh rather
than I taking that time from we have the
chancellors behind us we recognize
that there's that part of the part of
that equation comes back to the
legislature
um we appropriated money last year for
the Dual concurrent enrollment program
but when it came out of the house and
approved by the Senate the annual amount
was knocked down a million dollar and so
that meant that few our students could
take advantage of that program and that
is a a cost-saving driver for for
students so uh I believe that that
that's one area that we we need to be
looking at we have also looked at other
ways of uh uh driving home and I I think
that U uh Chancellor Rubenstein or
Chancellor Prov proventure can speak to
the possibilities what Nei has just
approved with the in relative relative
to a three-year degree um and and how
that might be a cost savings to students
as well uh also we have Grant guarantee
in there and expanding programs such as
that what you're often times looking at
the actual cost of what a a a student
has to pay for tuition it's not what
you're actually seeing some of our
students especially those that are
coming from the lower income levels are
having to pay Granite guarantee pays for
a good good hunk of that but that's
never seen so so we ought to look at net
as
well coruption s thank you um and thank
you for taking my question
so I'm curious because you talked about
the dual enrollment with high schools uh
the and and I forget the name of the
program because it's changed again but
when um my older daughter is a high
school as a college first year student
this year and many of her friends are
finding that the colleges are not
recognizing those credits and so I just
wasn't sure if there was
something um in this to make sure that
those dual enrollment between Community
College and High School courses are
being truly recognized those those
courses which are offered by the
community know system here in the state
are recognized the issue we have is we
have a lot of players in the game right
now I know the the school where my my
grandkids are going to school the Dual
concurrent enrollment is through
snow and that I I I'm not going to speak
to SN but uh I will speak to standards
academic standards and what are the
requirements for an individual who's Pro
providing that instruction in the
classroom uh we have the re uh uh
responsibity in this state to ensure
that that a instructor that's in the
high school providing the class meet the
standards of
accreditation and that means they have
to have a master's program excuse me in
the subject area um those all those
courses will be approved if it's that
way now there are some courses that you
may see that one has earned and they're
gen Ed courses that may not be
transferable to a program like
engineering at UNH their math program
may require
additional information or additional
instruction yes and that's another area
you might be asking those behind me um
but uh I have not heard that any of the
courses the running Start programs or
the Dual concurrent programs which are
being offered through through nhti have
not been accepted in our community
college system they have to be accepted
the money passes through them and and uh
from the legislature to them to provide
yeah represent represent luno thank you
very much Mr chair and I uh uh
appreciate the U opportunity to speak on
an amendment where I'm also a co-sponsor
on but um but representative llad and I
very much appreciate uh offering um well
to have the opportunity to offer this
amendment later when we exec the bill
but I was wondering if you could speak a
little bit to um what's
um um what's on um Roman 3 on the the
page two of the amendment and um and and
and basically how
how the amendment to um to
1450 is um uh re
really puts the you know puts a focus on
the uh the the task Force's final report
and the um um really the cooperation and
um and and work that will begin once the
final report is issued uh and um you
know to implement changes and and and
seek alignment uh among both the
community college system and the
university system and how that connects
with with a committee that exists
currently in the um um in the
legislature y the uh the committee
report which this is very draft and
everything I've given you as draft
speaks to those findings and
recommendations that will be implemented
or worked towards because we're not
there on on on some some of this more
short term we are moving that direction
but the long-term
Outlet is is going to be achieved and
what this does in paragraph Roman three
it identifies the two people are
absolutely
responsible for reporting back the two
Chancellor
and we're very fortunate to have these
two chancellors I think we're in a
position now where we have people that
have individuals who have communicated
worked with brought Provost in it's
their leadership that we we need to
engage with those chancellors were
responsible for bringing in these
quarterly reports and notice that the
quarter ending June 30th
2024 or as requested by the
committee we have the ability even to
back it off if we want uh however I I
think that that and with the annual
report which starts right off there will
be an annual report summarizing what
those quarterly reports are and where
we're going in terms that will help us
and
appropriating dollars where necessary so
we'll have that information for finance
to to work with and I'm hoping that
education policy and the the fiscal
people in the legislature will listen to
these reports there are some real needs
that we're encountering and it's got to
be a shared responsibility between
business and industry manufacturing and
it has to be shared with the legislature
and of course there has to be some
ownership on the part of the students as
well yes but we recognize there's many
needs here and I I just I I I I think
that that last Roman 3 paragraph is
really important because it explains the
process to be followed and without that
um it would have been another one of
these reports is put in the circular
file and we get what we get and so I'll
let the the folks behind me are really
into this not that I'm not but I know
that I know that uh Mr applebe has been
busy over there dedicating with his
associate their at least 25% of their
time right now over doe working on this
report it's a lot of work a lot going
into it and I know the chancellor just
I'm amazed each time I either call Kathy
or talk to Mark that there's something
else they're trying to do in terms of
how to work closer together I see that
bonding and that relationship now
stronger than I've ever seen it in the
past and we need to take advantage of it
and they are real quick follow up follow
up thank you Mr chair and and when you
talk about um the Chancellor's reporting
back to a committee you're not talking
about this committee you're talking
about higher education study Comm higher
education study that's correct committee
yes and uh and and how how it will then
put some structure to those meetings as
well to uh to to look at progress
towards the recommendation in this
report is that correct yes and the
higher education committee is mandated
by Statute to meet four times a year
more than that often uh the duties and
responsibilities are in law right now
and they have to have the hearing
process as we have a hearing process
every time they meet so it's very very
transparent further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative next Chancellor prenter
from uh the university system thank you
here uh good morning Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Katherine preventure I serve as the
chief administrative officer of our
states University system and um with
representative lad representative luno
and a number of others I've been um
actively participating on the governor's
task force since December
21st um we are in support of this
amendment this bill um chanc Rubenstein
and I have already been working on
implementing some of the recommendations
that are in the draft report um
including sharing office space we just
did a walk through last week um chancell
Rubenstein and I have um standing
bi-weekly meetings where we talk about
other ways we can collaborate we've come
up with a long list of
possibilities I do see the the
the the task force report as a road map
we will then need to really develop
implementation plans on implementing uh
the recommendations that are in the
report um so again I I'll be brief we're
we're supportive of the work and
Reporting back to the public highered
study committee and furthering
collaboration um across the two systems
to benefit all the
citizenry I'll take any questions thank
you very much questions from the
committee yes represent s thank you just
to follow so are are you saying as as I
asked uh chairman lad my question has to
do at the running start because I'm
hearing from students who are at
University system schools that their
running starts are not necessarily being
recognized my school participates with
um Great Bay Community College for those
programs and and they are teachers that
are supposedly doing this but kids are
taking the courses and then getting
there and discovering they have to
retake classes that they thought they
completed so just trying to understand
where the breakdown sure I I'm not aware
of specific um credits that are not
being transferred um I would love to
touch base with you and find out what
those courses are it's my understanding
I know anecdotally that um some of my
friends they're their um children their
credits did transfer so I I'd really
like to um touch base offline and get
some specifics and I'll dig into
that thank you reg Miler thank you thank
you for being here question that I have
is that as you look at this road map
going
forward what role do students
play in the decision
making as you Mo move forward well
actually the task force um one of our
meetings we did get input from students
um from all of the University system
campuses as well as um community college
students so there's absolutely an
awareness that we need to engage with
students and I will say we've also had a
lot of conversation around not just
students students that are in our public
higher ed institutions but
students um in the K through2 system
that that the community college system
and the university system could be a
little more intentional about our
intersection with um working with k12
and the CTE centers so um representative
Miler I think that's we're well aware of
the importance of engaging with
students and represent
luno Thank you very much Mr chair so um
and thank you very much um Chancellor
for for um being here this morning one
of the magic words I think in in the um
uh in the amendment and uh and it's in
the um it's in the title and it's used
in the in the draft report is the word
alignment and uh and I think one of and
this sort of goes to I think
Representatives um SE and Myers's um
previous two
questions alignment when it comes to
meeting student needs alignment when it
comes to um um
meeting e or or achieving efficiencies
within the um the and and we've most
recently talked about the three systems
the university system the community
college system and K12 um in New
Hampshire and then finally alignment
when it comes to meeting the state's
needs for um for business development
and Workforce and I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about what
alignment uh means and I know that's a
little bit of a of a report preview but
uh but you know it's it's definitely
Central toh to this U uh Amendment as
well certainly the the task force and
again um I'll reiterate reiterate what
representative Vlad previously stated
around draft recommendations right now
in the report because obviously it has
not been issued but um a topic that the
task force has discussed and um is
considering recommending are Regional
and
Statewide um councils if you will or
tapping into so I'll go to Economic
Development first there are already
Regional um Economic
Development groups that meet and ccsnh
and usnh should be participating and
have a seat in the table there again be
more intentional with um Economic
Development Workforce of course as I've
mentioned um really the only way we can
impact a Workforce is if we have
enrollment so and the same we've been
discussing relative to K12 ccsnh usnh
more Regional ongoing not
oneandone um relationships around the
state
between all of Education every level to
ensure that we're um meeting the needs
of all of our students who wish to go on
to further their education however that
looks um Beyond high school did I answer
your question okay
great thank you further questions
representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
your work and for helping us with this
I'm wondering if you could inform us a
bit about line 22 where it says do
improve accessibility and compatibility
for New Hampshire students
specifically does that in some way
Encompass um representative Myer's
earlier question about student debt and
financing because I am also concerned
that that huge issue is not apparent
here so I I think it absolutely does
relative to accessibility and
compatibility one size doesn't fit all
for all students um so if students
students can take those courses um in
high school that can then transfer to
the community college system you it's
possible that students could actually
leave high school with an associates
degree um and the other the other part
of it is a degree
isn't maybe what everyone wants or needs
there are certificate programs um could
work with business and industry on
tailoring those so and and we've talked
at the task force also about there are
likely many students in high school
where education Beyond high school isn't
even a twinkle in their eye so how do we
engage with those students um I will say
as a former State Treasurer um relative
to student debt I think another big
piece of that is financial
literacy um for families and students
before they get to us um I don't know
how to solve that but that's actually a
not just a state issue that's a national
issue
so it's not exactly fall it's a separate
question okay um and now I just forgot
what it was sorry come back to me sorry
for the
questions one more chance representative
Damon or afterwards thank you thank you
thank you very much for being
Rubenstein I'm sorry comic relief on
Monday
morning I just wanted to hear your
remarks in terms of what if anything the
task force has been addressing in terms
of collaboration with CTE programs and
whether dual enrollment works with that
student population as well
we haven't done a deep the task force
has not done a deep dive into CTE and
dual enrollment we have had discussions
that many of the CTE programs in the
state are over subscribed and there are
waiting lists um but that's that is
woven into the draft recommendations in
report thank
you
welcome
Chancellor do you want to press the
thank you representative cordelli good
morning and thank you to the committee
and uh thank you to director applebe and
Dr marks for their leadership and
stewardship of the task force and also
the chief administrative officer of
preventure couldn't ask for a better
partner in working with the university
system um specific to House Bill 1450 I
I support it uh we we share a set of
objectives and providing more access to
postsecondary education high quality
postsecondary education in New Hampshire
is really vital for folks who've heard
me speak before you know that I I
believe that this is an area of absolute
growth in terms of need and as
representative lad described earlier you
know part part of the population we
serve is not simply the students coming
out of high school um about almost 40%
of our students are 25 or older they
account for about that proportion of our
graduates in fact more than 40% of our
graduates in that group specific to the
kinds of Education that they're looking
for the kinds of students that we're
serving we are currently enrolling about
400 students in our nursing programs
across the seven colleges one in five of
those students already holds a bachelor
degree in some other field these are
adults who find what they need to do in
life find their calling at later stage
and need education that's accessible in
terms of place in terms of time and in
terms of affordability fitting into the
competing pressures that they face so I
I believe that the work that the task
force has been doing the work that this
committee would be asked to uh continue
to oversee is part of a Statewide
commitment to ensure that we are doing
the best we can with the resources we
have to support all of our
students um a number of questions have
come up about um dual enrollment I think
I can proba probably try and answer some
of those one one of the considerations
and this is true not just for our dual
enrollment program sometimes for
advanced placement other forms of of
college level learning that happens at
high school is that institutions decide
that students are better served by
having the Full Experience immersed in
that College's uh
programs but more often I think the
barrier is simply that the courses that
students take through dual enrollment
are often just one or two
courses and don't really move the needle
on the issue of
affordability if you're a full-time
student at UNH I believe you can take up
to 18 credits before you might face a SE
charge for overload uh in Community
College our students are typic paying by
the credit for the course because the
majority of them are part-time students
but at most four-year institutions Balor
granting institutions students pay for a
semester and then they can consume as
much education as their as their brains
uh can can handle and so a student who's
taken a couple of courses may just wash
through no real impact what
representative lad was speaking about in
terms of access what we're really trying
to create are genuinely com
comprehensive structured Pathways for
students uh this body I believe now
three years ago passed House Bill U 1530
the pathways Bill between the community
college system and the university system
one of our objectives would be to
actually anchor those Pathways with
Early College courses that students
could take while still in high school
have the opportunity to begin that
foundation and not just take one or two
courses but over the course of their
High School careers potentially take a
full semester a full year or a complete
associate degree that's where you're
going to start to see meaningful savings
the avoidance of debt that
representative Miler had asked about
that's really the vision that we have
for strengthening dual enrollment as an
antidote to cost for traditional age
students still in high school where we
can have that kind of impact and the
primary consideration is it's not just
affordability but it's access to Quality
so part of the challenge is making sure
that the faculty and high schools have
the academic preparation to deliver the
curriculum that we offer under our
accreditation through New England
Commission on higher education that
typically requires a master's prepared
individual in the discipline that
they're teaching one of the objectives
we have and one of the things that was
enabled through House Bill 2 last year
was some flexibility this body has in
the past granted us support for
scholarships for students to take those
dual enrollment sometimes running
running start eart more generally Early
College courses we also find that with
flexibility in the language we can
actually have our faculty delivering
some of those courses in high schools
that don't necessarily have the
academically qualified faculty to teach
a particular course in a particular
discipline Again part of the broader
vision of ensuring access to highquality
Affordable post-secondary education for
New Hampshire students in the
future um H happy to answer questions
the one piece that I would draw
attention to from the uh the bill itself
as a reference to um uh collocating
spaces office spaces both the university
system the community college system but
also state agencies I I would take that
a step further legislature Governor
invest significantly in our work I would
like for us not just to have state
agencies collocated with us I'd really
like for the state to look at us as
partners in delivering the need
responding to the needs that you have
for the state's own work Force 11,000
folks working on behalf of the state to
serve the citizens of New Hampshire the
same thing that I would say for any
employer in this state changing
technology competitive environment you
need the strongest Workforce you can
have as Educators who specialize in
supporting the learning for adults we we
could be good partners in helping to
ensure that the state continues to meet
the needs of its citizens in that
context thank you very much
representative
TR thank you thank you for taking my
question um I had a son who went through
the community college system and then
graduated from Plymouth it was a great
experience for him are there any
Community College deserts in the state
of New Hampshire where it's not
accessible well I'm I'm reluctant to say
that there are genuine deserts uh White
Mountains Community College has probably
the largest geography similar to
Executive counselor uh Kenny District uh
uh pretty much the entire North Country
Lakes past uh up to Canada uh but we
have locations in Berlin and Littleton
we partner with kennet high school and
Conway deliver courses maybe more
generally it's helpful to know that
about 30% of our instruction these days
is occurring online so that as long as
somebody has access to the internet we
can reach them with a lot of our
programs um long-term Vision again along
with dual enrollment and trying to find
better ways to serve adult workers is to
partner with employers throughout the
state to be able to deliver courses both
on our locations and I partner uh
locations to be able to meet those needs
for things that are more tactile more
more Hands-On
learning yes thank you a different
subject um I was on the commission to
study uh education U hospitality and and
um that kind of education in the state
and so I'm wondering
if how well you stay on top of trends
for where U jobs are going in the state
of New Hampshire um thank you
representative drive that question that
each of our colleges has an Advisory
Board that's more GE geographically
based but each of our programs also has
an academic program Advisory Board
specifically with that intention
probably we can do better part of the
discussion the task force with Deputy
Commissioner lers has been ensuring that
we've got a good flow of information
from new Hamp Employment Security about
Labor Trends to understand make sure
we're not missing U demands that are
shifting you're
welcome further questions yeah
representative C thank you and thank you
for taking my question in terms of the
Community College uh instructors
qualifications and the running starter
dual enrollment you said they have to
have a master's degree can that be a
masters in anything or does it need to
be specific to the subject they're
teaching the the intent is to be a
master's in the subject that they're
teaching that's consistent with our own
uh requirements for faculty teaching on
our campuses and and with an objective
in of ensuring the consistency of
learning whether it's through dual
enrollment on our campuses online and we
believe that that's a critical element
you're welcome further questions seen
none thank you very much for being
Department
good morning thank you representative
cordelli and thank you members of of the
uh committee um my name is Steve Appleby
I'm the director of educator support and
higher education at the department of Ed
and also the chair of the uh task force
that uh has been convenient convening uh
I want to lead with letting everyone
know that on Friday uh before the close
of the task force meeting we did take a
vote on the proposed amendment and it
was unanimous
uh in recommending uh to this committee
that you have the support of the task
force uh for this
amendment um we've been meeting pretty
much weekly since New Year's every
Friday as uh chair lad mentioned it's
been uh representative luno as well it's
it's been uh you know they've had their
mail forwarded on Fridays to to the doe
and we're um uh getting through the work
uh many many great ideas I have to I
want to publicly thank the task force
because there's been tremendous
participation and uh lot lots of lots of
really good discussion lotss of really
good ideas um you know and a couple of
themes that we haven't really talked too
much about one of which I want to I want
to mention here because it's come up
this morning and that's the college debt
issue right college debt is a real
problem um I I I agree with uh Vice
Chancellor prenta that um financial
literacy in our country is a huge issue
uh not just of kids but of adults I have
personally helped friends uh fill out
financial aid forms for their children
children and these are friends who are
Highly Educated uh one is an attorney
and a very good attorney and that
financial aid uh process was very very
complex and convoluted so um you know
the the debt piece I I I view it more of
a
symptom than um an end result and it's a
symptom from the standpoint I think of
one financial literacy and I think two
one of the issues at least that we face
in New Hampshire and this brings back to
the task force why it was formed is
declining enrollment if we look at our
demographics Cher I mentioned this we're
seeing a one to two% drop every year in
our uh K to2 enrollments in our state
which means there are less 18y olds
right at the end of the at the end of
that um time and I think one of the one
of the pieces that we we don't always
keep in mind is that most colleges are
what in business we call the fixed cost
model those buildings those
grounds you can't easily undo those
costs right if you build a building you
have to maintain it and whether you have
a building that's half full of students
taking classes or completely full that
maintenance charge is not that different
and so as as enrollments decline costs
per student go up it's the same problem
we're having in K12 those of youve
looked at the K12 numbers so I think one
of you know one of the problems
sometimes with debt is we talk
about you know the the the sticker price
side but we don't look at the inputs
that going into creating that debt and
you know one of the goals of this task
force was how can we increase
enrollments because if we canre increase
enrollments in our public systems 15 or
20% that would allow for cost
stabilization because they'd be filling
their classes and that would
theoretically lower costs for students
which would affect that so um just again
keeping in mind the focus of the task
force is really looking at looking ahead
to the Future and what type of of postc
educational system do we want in our
state what are the new trends out there
what can we do to arrest this declining
enrollment issue um and that that's been
the focus so uh again task force uh was
unanimous in support of this amendment
and um happy to take any
questions thank you uh representative
luno thanks very much Mr chair and thank
you very much director applebe for uh
being with us this morning and for um
obviously your your leadership um uh on
the task force as well um I want to go
back to the um the amendment and and and
pick up another important word right out
of the the title but um it talks about
findings that are identified in the
governor's public higher education task
force report and you and I have spoken
about the importance of the the findings
in here and um and I I guess I'd like to
sort of hear from you uh about um how um
how we can make sure that the um that
the as this report draft uh becomes you
know more final in the next uh in the
next week literally that um that it it
that it has the um the the necessary
elements in the um in the report that
will um uh really be consistent with the
the you know the actions that are being
required in the the amendment to
1450 thank you representative for the
question so um part of our process has
been from the beginning of the uh uh
from the first task force meeting has
been to educate the members of the task
force um we have spent a great deal of
time really looking at um whether it's
studies that have been done around the
country other initiatives in other
states what's going on across highered
around the country and as part of that
process we've also identified some some
key pieces in our own state which
representative low Leno mentions uh
findings of various things for example
findings such as uh the number of high
school seniors graduating in our state
uh right now hovering uh just under
15,000 around 15,000 a year is down
significantly from 20 years ago when
that number was um if I'm not mistaken
was up around 20,000 a year well that
5,000 student dropped it's 25% drop in
20 years right that uh that finding is a
drive of some of the recommendations uh
another I think uh
recommendation having to do with um uh
online education and availability of
classes online again finding is online
education especially coming out of the
pandemic has really gone mainstream so
to speak I mean we don't need to look
much further than a college within our
own state that has almost 150,000
students because they've gone online and
they've made that process of the process
of of uh of applying and uh the
admissions process the financial aid
process they've streamlined all of it um
they're not Amazon right how easy it is
to buy but they're not far off and again
we've another Finding has been how hard
is it for students to to apply and get
accepted and sign up for a class
representative L you L know you had a
great great example of that on Friday at
our meeting around trying to take a
class at one of our public institutions
and it was not a simple process to
enroll in the class right so I think our
findings uh will be examples that
support exactly the the the initiatives
and recommendations we're going to put
forward thank you thank you represent D
thank you thanks for taking my question
could you inform us what uh proportion
of New
Hampshire freshman college
students um go to school in New
Hampshire as opposed to going to a
private or public institution out of
state and whether that ratio has changed
in the last decade or
so thank you for the question that's a
that's a great question and I wish I had
a an answer um I do not we uh we collect
some data at the department
around uh the that the question that you
asked however I am told um by one of my
fellow directors who collects that data
and it might be the worst data she
collects because it is voluntarily
reported by guidance counselors around
the state so we don't have a great
handle on that and when we look at iPads
in fact I was just looking this morning
uh at a report from last year uh it I
can't give you numbers but I can tell
you a significant number of our students
leave the state and it is significant um
compared to staying in and how that is
historically trending I that I couldn't
answer but it is certainly a concern
many I I believe if we're not the
largest exporter of college students
we're one of the largest on a per capita
basis around the country so yeah and
we've actually talked about this at the
task force extensively and that desire
of high schoolers you know to to get out
of town to get away from their families
to get out on their own and whereas if
you're in in Texas it's a huge State you
can go six hours away and still be in
Texas in New Hampshire if you go six
hours away you're practically in DC so
um that that you know geography
certainly plays a role but some of it is
the 18 19 year old mindset of I want to
get away I want to try new things
so
yes thank you and I would concur that
part of it is the get out of Dodge as it
were but I will also note that when my
daughters who are now in their early 30s
were choosing colleges it was
considerably less expensive for them to
go out of
state so if that hasn't changed and I
don't think it
has we are partly losing students
because of the economy that they
think I'm in suin County so it could be
different in different parts of the
state but the perception of the quality
of
unh is not as high as what I think is
the quality of unh so I think it's
sometimes perhaps
frequently perceived as the default the
safety
School versus way back in the Dark Ages
I grew up in the shadows of UMass
amst and a lot of the local high school
students actually wanted to go there it
wasn't a default choice I think it's a
marketing issue that's not really a
question
sorry um for further
questions
of yes yep and and if there are no
further questions I just want to end
also want to thank two other individuals
whove Been instrumental uh in this
process and that is um Vice Chancellor
preventure and chanc Rubenstein who have
both put in uh really a lot of effort
and really kept open minds and that
that's made our work I think um more
productive more beneficial and and quite
frankly easier so I want to thank you
both of them thank you for that um see
no further questions oh
yes answer representative D's question I
um this is to answer your question about
the number of students who go out of
state to seek higher education and my
numbers are based on 4 your college
goers so not of all the high school
graduates those that state go to CCF so
about
56% of our 4-year College goers leave
the state to attend college and it is
one of the highest in the country um
I'll also note that the number of out
ofate students that we have coming in
provides the biggest inmigration of
talent while while they're here and if
if we can keep them here another driver
for our economy and our
Workforce thank yes quickly please thank
you so how does our out of state
enrollment compared to other comparable
state
universities so our we're about 50/50
across the university system um that's
lower than Vermont for example UVM I
think maybe 75 to 80% of their students
are out of state students um
Massachusetts probably has a higher
percentage of instate students than we
do um I can tell you when you get
outside of New
England the majority of
students um in I'll use Texas as an
example are
inate right um I do think that has to do
with the supply of choices of schools in
in the Northeast compared to out west
but um so we're about we're about 5050
and we've been there for for some
amendment okay thank you chairman quell
good morning thank you you follow up in
year 56% um that's the youngsters who
are leaving in fouryear program
okay do you have any uh stats or
estimations amount the come
back as we lose 4 56 I'm sure there's a
percentage of those students that come
back after a year waste they need you
know sometimes home is better than way
do we have any other stats on that I
don't have those with me representative
but I I will check on that okay thank
you very much thank you Mr chairman
thank you uh see another nothing further
thank you very much um both of you every
for being here is there anyone else who
wanted to testify on the 1450
Amendment seeing none we can uh close
everybody so um who's filling in this
because the official these are these are
the emails yeah so um sing for Tanner
okay
solivan SE okay that's all so s ten okay
what's her first name huh representative
s what's that Brian solivan no Cel Cel I
I don't know you don't need what is your
first
name Lauren okay thank
you yeah I think so we want to cof right
yeah we
will can we have a restroom break yeah
we're going to just open up and then
we're going to CAU us
okay okay for for those in the committee
here's what we're going to be doing
we're just going to open up the
executive session then we're going to
take a break for a caucus and walking
down to the
WC okay so with that I'm going to open
up the executive sessions for today and
at this time we are going to be
attending to caucus work and
you
e
students in
school you have anything you want to of
WID ET ET for well thank you Mr chairman
I I had a a pleasant email from my State
Rep uh representative Hall who on this
committee somewhere she is um that you
were discussing this bill and thought
that uh maybe some input for me would be
helpful um I probably would be better
off answering questions uh if you have
them but I I will just say that
uh e efforts to register high school
students has been uh in existence for
some time
and we uh encourage supervisors of the
checklist and town clerks uh that want
to conduct a a voter registration
opportunity for students in high school
uh to do that uh but there are some
caveats uh to that number one is that uh
when there is a registration drive it is
a public event and it cannot be
restricted or limited to just a certain
group or certain class of people so you
know if if the supervisors are willing
to do a registration drive for high
school students uh let's say it should
be an open Event so that other members
of the community could take advantage of
the same
opportunity uh but then if there are
other groups in town that would like
that same opportunity then the
supervisors of the checklist should be
willing to do that if the if the uh uh
you know local veterans organization
wants to have a registration drive for
some of their younger members or or
whoever uh then the supervisor should be
willing to do the same thing and it
should also be a public event so that uh
you know anybody that's interested in
taking advantage of getting registered
can do
that there is also concerns about
offering something of value either
Financial value or you know or or or
person personal value to get registered
to vote so uh you know you can't give uh
uh ice cream cones just to those people
that show up to register to vote and
nobody else uh you you can't give A's to
students uh because they went and
registered to vote uh you you don't want
anything that comes close to the
perception of buying a voter's
registration or or vote so that's very
very
important uh in New Hampshire a a a
citizen uh that's qualified that wants
to register to vote has to do it
personally in front of an election
official specifically a supervisor of
the checklist or town
clerk uh teachers for example cannot
hand out registration forms in their
classroom and have students fill them
out
um unless it's a registration drive and
there is an election official present at
that
event the
um the last thing I'll say before uh
I'll take questions is
that 15 months ago I had that special
committee on voter confidence that went
around the state and uh that that group
heard from the whole range of Voters ERS
and ideas perspectives uh in New
Hampshire it was a really great exercise
uh and we learned that there are some
things that are uh agreed upon across
the board in that process and and one of
those is uh just doing more with Civics
uh and voter
education uh and engaging not just
students but you know our our whole
population and so over the last few
months we have been engaging in efforts
to knew just that um one of the big
events that we had was partnering with
an organization called vet the vote and
we actually set up a mock polling place
uh in
marac uh which was uh each of the
stations in a polling place was manned
by uh veterans who were also local
election officials and it was an
opportunity for other veterans to come
in and see exactly what happens in a
polling place uh but it was also open to
the general public um and the kicker
there was that the the uh vet the vote
program is also partnered with the NFL
so we had three former New England
Patriot players there and that helped
draw some turnouts so that was a good
event um one big plan that I have uh
organized for the summer is bringing on
a person uh into the office Who as a
former educator and starting a a Civic
space program for direct Outreach to
voters uh you know we'll be looking at
uh high school students college students
but also just get getting messaging out
to the general public about how our
elections actually work uh in an effort
to uh reduce the amount of
misinformation that is out there related
to the election
process so with that I'd be happy to
have thank you Mr chair and thank you
secretary for being here um so can you
speak it all to what law or case law or
best practices sort of exist around
policies of who is allowed and how they
are allowed to assist voters with voting
or with
registering so the law is very
clear as I mentioned that only
supervisors of the checklist uh and or
the town clerk accept voter registration
forms directly from voters and when they
do that they are reviewing the
information on the form uh and then they
are looking at the backup
documentation that is provided to prove
uh identity age citizenship and
domicile and in New Hampshire we do have
affidavits that a voter consign you know
to prove those things that's the state
of the law at the current time but those
are items that are provided to those
election officials and then the election
officials will take them back and in a
in an advertised session we'll vote on
them to add those names to the voter
checklist in New Hampshire only
supervisors of the checklist can add
names to the voter checklist or remove
names from the checklist even the
Secretary of State cannot do that it's
those locally elected individuals that
uh have that
responsibility
um and so it is within the statutory
authority of those election officials to
not only take registrations when they're
in meeting or uh at the clerk's office
but they can hold
events either in a school or at the
local VFW or you know at the at the town
uh fair in the summertime you know they
can have a table set up where qualified
people have an opportunity uh outside of
vote as a school principal or as a
social studies teacher I'd like to
engage this process in my classroom if I
have a supervisor of the checklist come
in to uh register students
on the format and addressing those four
points that you
mentioned then do the the supervisor now
has this form is that taken back to the
supervisors of the checklist for
approval or is it approved upon the
individual supervisor dealing with it in
the in the classroom so in in a
situation like that if if a supervisor
is going to go someplace and take
registration
then it has to be an advertised event it
it can't be a private event it it should
be advertised just like they're holding
you know a a session for receiving
applications um and then at that event
the registration forms would be
collected uh and then T taken back so
that the Board of Supervisors has the
opportunity to vote on the applications
and accept them and then put those names
on the checklist
and I'll just follow up and then the
rest of the committee is that a event at
the school in the classroom a singular
event only for students or can somebody
walk in off the street and say I want to
take advantage of this situation and
um it should be held in a location not
specifically a classroom so that the
general public can come in if they want
to register as
well the the the issue with schools when
these events are held in schools is
sometimes a lot of high schools are
Regional high
schools and the students that attend
that school are from different towns
within the region a supervisor of the
checklist can only accept registrations
from uh citizens of their town so if it
was going to be a you know if the school
was going to sponsor an event like that
uh and there's four towns in the school
district then ideally there should be a
representative there from the four towns
uh supervisors of the checklist so that
uh each student has the opportunity to
do that if if the election officials
from town
C are not there then the students who
would be voters in town C would not be
able to register at that
event I have another question I want to
ask you represent Hall at this time
represent Hall thank you Mr chair and
thank you for being here and thank you
for taking my question uh in a letter
you wrote to the supervisor of the
checklist in
2023 uh you had said the public notice
and access to the event are not required
if a single supervisor attending the
event to receive
applications is
that is that no longer the case like the
Quorum thing and
the um I I want to just look back and
and double check uh you know the
circumstances that that uh was written
my understanding has been that that that
when registrations are taken that they
are public
events okay um can I follow up actually
read want me to read you exactly what it
said I was kind of mixing it all up um a
single supervisor attending an event to
receive applications that will not be
acted on until a subsequent supervisor
session is not a public meeting of the
board therefore public notice and access
to the event are not required so that's
I just want okay so if that's what's
written that's the way it is um you know
butd fit I'm sure approved that uh butd
fit is the legal counsil for the
Secretary of State's office um but the
the the key part there was that the
registrations would not be approved at
that event correct okay thank you
further questions yes represent s then
represent dry thank you you um I'm
wondering just if a Civics teacher had
their students filling out sort of the
basic information in those forms for the
students to then take back to their town
clerk's office to to sign and and
provide all the necessary documents
would that be still within the realm of
what's legal so that they're you know
because having I live in Durham and have
volunteered at a number of Elections and
been sworn to assist with this process
and we advise people as they're filling
things out to get to to a certain line
and stop and not sign anything till the
supervisor is there monitoring and that
they're the ones in fact signing and
providing their documents so if a
teacher had students doing just the
initial portion would that be and then
the student takes it with them is that
that would not be permitted uh we do not
make the registration forms publicly
available um because ultimately what
happens is a voter will fill one of
those out and then mail in and that's
just not the way it works in New
Hampshire
um
um so uh that would not be permissible
um there is a bill in the legislature
right now that would that would create a
voter portal which would allow voters
potential voters on their laptop to fill
out the information that would be
required on a voter registration form
and that would be sent then to the
supervisors of the
checklist uh they would review it uh
they would bring a copy with them to the
polls and then that voter would have to
show up either at the polling place or
go to the uh supervisor's meeting and
sign the forms and show the
documentation and the benefit of doing
that is that the the information is
provided by the voter in electronic form
which would say the supervisors from
having to transfer
illegibly ill legibly written
handwritten forums and enter that into
the database they'd be able to just
transfer once they approve the
application and then it should
streamline uh the time it takes for a
voter to that's registering to vote to
move through the polling place if they
pre-fill that information
out thank you represent dry thank you
thank you Mr Secret take my question I
just want to go a little in the weeds
with representative Hall's letter uh was
that the at school it would not be a
with a with one supervisor there that
would not be a board meeting so it
wouldn't have to be um announce as in
public now is that different than having
that event open to the public so that
people members of the public could also
come along with high school students to
register
like what kind of a meeting or what kind
of announcement would be required or
needed if the supervisors are meeting to
actually place names on the checklist or
take names off the checklist uh that
that's noticed as a SE session for the
correction of the
checklist and at that meeting the there
has to be a quorum of Supervisors pres
so that they can vote uh on the
applications that they've received and
whether those names get placed on the
checklist or
not yes so we're having this event at
the high school public is invited or
announced is it's announced that it's
taking place so that members that
members of the public can also take
advantage of based on what my uh
notification that got sent out to local
election officials some time ago it
sounds like an event could be held
without notice to the
public um as long as there is uh one
supervisor present would that would not
be an official session of Supervisors it
would just be it would be it would be
like
um a a new voter going into the clerk's
office and filling out the application
form um showing the clerk documentation
because the clerk is authorized to do
that but the clerk cannot put that name
on the checklist the clerk then has to
take that application and give it to to
the the uh Board of Supervisors of the
checklist to then vote by majority vote
to accept it one more go ahead so it's
so it is a limited then event because it
wouldn't be open to the public that's
that's that seems to be the case yes
okay yeah I'm going to confirm that but
but you know if if the notice went out
from my office I'm I'm sure
you go ahead uh Woodcock did represent
Woodcock do you I saw your hand up go
first did
you leus yeah you're welcome well I just
wanted to follow that up given what we
just talked about um would they still
need to have a supervisor of the
checklist from each Town represented by
the
school that would make the most sense if
it's a multi- if it's a Regional School
District yeah I mean if if if part of
that process is to educate the voters
and give them an opportunity then uh the
event should have at least one
supervisor from each of the towns in the
you representa Woodcock thank you
chairman L good morning Mr secretary
thank you for being here um something
much easier can you have a a guess for
us a ballpark guest how many 18 to 20
year olds 21y olds in New Hampshire
register uh I don't I don't have a guess
top of my head although you know I did
listen to the to the discussion that you
had last time and rip I think you tossed
a figure out uh when you were discussing
that those figures are a little bit uh
deceptive in that and it's in the way
the other states report their data
compared to New Hampshire so New
Hampshire has election day registration
and there is a a growing number of
states now that you know they're going
in that direction but in many states the
registrations have to be have to take
place you know as as early as 30 days
before the election and so those states
are able to report their uh registration
numbers uh faster than new hampture sure
when many of most of the registrants do
it on the day of the election and so uh
New Hampshire may not be as high as the
national average but I think they were
it would be higher
once all those final numbers come in uh
uh uh when you look at that but but the
bottom line is it's the registrations of
Youth are are relatively low and uh you
know the trick is to get them if they do
it once if they register to vote and
they vote then they tend to continue to
do it and and I think that's you know
that's we wouldn't encourage them to do
that so that so that participate and uh
you know once they get involved in that
process they tend to stick with it thank
you Mr secretary thank you Mr chairman
thank you uh secretary scand and I have
one question follow up to the example
you gave us about uh the Regional High
School with students from towns a c and
d the question is is it discriminatory
if Town C students are not afforded the
D well I I think it would be if
you know if uh in the process of
organizing this you know towns a b and d
were invited and town C was not um but
if they were all invited uh and uh you
know one of them was for whatever reason
unable to make it um and if they were
willing to you know create an
opportunity you know that that might
work outside of that event then uh I
think it depends on the situation
whether it would be discriminatory or
not
there are some communities that do not
want to engage in in this activity in
schools and so if Town C was one that
did not want to engage and uh kids from
a b and d were provided that opportunity
what recourse would the kids from town C
have saying hey I wasn't afforded this
opportunity where other high school
students in this school were afforded
that opportunity I I would hope that in
a situation like that that that the
students from town C would be informed
of how to register to vote and where
they could go and do it um you know and
uh you know you know they're 18 right
they can they can vote uh they can
register to vote uh when they're 17 as
long as they will be 18 before the next
election and so 18yar olds are adults um
and uh you know they they assume some
responsibility and and uh you know if
that opportunity is not available for
them uh on Election Day or when they
have the event at the school then I
suppose they could uh you know take the
initiative to visit the clerk or a
supervisor's meeting or just show up at
the polls on the day of the election
committee rson Hall thank you Mr chair
and thank you again for taking my
question so I'm just curious let's see
if the
single um town clerk goes and does the
voter registration Drive she gets the
all the the pile of registrations now
when she goes back to the the group they
go one by one to accept it they don't
just say Okay this whole pack was done
the same way one by one they would go
one by one
and and vote on uh and and and then vote
on the individuals that they're going to
approve yes can I have one more please
one more um you said before the next
election does it matter what kind of
election it is whether it's a primary or
presidential or a local no it's before
the next election yeah yeah because in
in New Hampshire you have to be 18 years
old to vote so um if you have a town
election uh before a prime
primary uh and and the student won't
turn 18 until after the town election
then the student could not register to
vote uh before the town election thank
you thank you very represent Cornell
thank you and thank you secretary for
taking my question would it be safe to
assume that town clerks or are people
who do this in cities and towns know the
rules for how to do it and what's requ
fired or and if they had questions they
would check with your office before they
went into a school and registered kids
in a class and and didn't give out
public notice yes there are many
long-term clerks and long-term
supervisors of the checklist uh who know
how this process works and the newer
ones uh and we are seeing a lot of
turnover in those positions now through
elections uh uh they don't hesitate to
call uh if they have questions and you
know one of the initiatives that I would
like to see is not is I mean it's
important to get them to register to
vote but we would like to take it to
another level and and get them to
volunteer in polling places um and you
know get
some uh younger people that you know
want to participate as supervisors of
the checklist
because uh some of those individuals
have been doing that job for 30 40 even
50 years and you know we have to find
replacements for
them oh we're all getting a little wider
here not everybody represent demon it's
getting grayer thank you thank you for
taking my question I was wondering if
you could just update us on what the
training for supervisors of the
checklist is and
also am I correct that in order to be a
supervisor you have to be
18 you have to be
to be an an election official at the
local level you have to be 18 years old
U you have to live uh in the town or the
city Ward um and
uh um you have to be a United States
citizen you have to meet you know the
those requirements and then
um the in terms of the training prior to
every election cycle uh whether it's
presidential primary or whether it's the
fall elections every two years we have
um uh been ex expanding the training
opportunities but we start with about a
dozen uh two and a half to three hour
training sessions that we take around
the state so we visit each County uh you
know go all the way up to C Brook
sometimes and you know over to Keen down
on the Sea Coast and everywhere in
between and and we create opportun
unities for uh uh moderators clerks and
supervisors of the checklist to come in
so that uh they can learn the process
number one but two we make them aware of
all the Law changes that take place
every every
year and then in addition to that we
have been uh recording training sessions
and putting them up on YouTube and then
we have been doing uh training videos
that are specific to the individual
roles in the polling place whether it's
a supervisor of the checklist or a
ballot Clerk or uh a moderator uh we're
trying to make the training as available
and as convenient to everybody that
process representa Hall thank you Mr
chair just to followup to that I as a
ballot clerk in this past election I
watched those videos and it was superb I
knew how to do everything I needed to do
thank
you the legislature try to change that
though so he won't know what everything
you did um uh secretary have you have
you talked with ID ltin who has got the
commission right now in in looking at
Civics education within our schools
textbook Etc um and you spoke at the
very beginning of your presentation or
working with us today that you were
looking down the road at a program which
could be used from an educational
perspective in the school tools are you
you know linking it up with oit who is
also right now they're right in the
process of letting a contract out and uh
moving forward with a design program I
was curious to know if you are aware of
that I have not spoken with ID uh on on
that topic um but I think whatever they
decide to do will be compatible with uh
you know with our initiative it's um
we've been doing a really good job uh
conducting the elections and and
training the pole workers and uh and
communicating them uh the one area that
we need to spend more time on is
communicating to the voters themselves
and and so um you know I'm anxious to
see what the Civics commission comes up
with uh but whatever it is it will be
our initiative will be uh an enhancement
okay to that thank you yes
representative sing thank you um very
quickly so first um just to follow up on
uh representative Damon's question I
believe you have to also be registered
to vote in the district where you're a
supervisor and then my other question is
um are you aware of an organization
called my school votes which creates
voting clubs in schools um not in New
Hampshire because kids can't
pre-register here but in other places a
nonpartisan effort to get students to
learn about the voting process in order
to encourage their peers to vote and to
support that yeah I'm I'm not aware of
that organization um uh number one
number two is uh you have to be a
registered voter uh to work as an
official in the polls except that the
law does allow for 17year olds to uh
work in a polling place and you know we
really want to encourage you know that
type of participation thank you for the
clarification actually my student got
her NHS hours that way
represent cordelli thank you thank you
for being here secretary um I just want
to mention RSA
18923 which relates to uh the State
Board of Education Distributing copies
of the Constitution and election laws to
teachers in high schools um this dates
back to the 30s um it had been lost
somewhere along the line I've contacted
uh the State Board chair and the uh Comm
and they are going to start to do that
but I just wanted you to be aware of you
know they were going to be sending out
information on Election laws so you know
maybe some coordination there might be
helpful as well y that would be good we
do uh every year publish constitutions
for the fourth graders I think uh in in
the state of New Hampshire and and there
otherwise they're generally available
and I know the finance committee has
been looking at a bill that would
require us to publish a lot more copies
of the Constitution so that they could
distributed I have one more things
twirling around up here uh we have a
requirement to any student that comes K
through 12 we must enroll whether
they're a citizen of the country or
not um we have a number of students
we've had in past years the Val
Victorian coming forward and testifying
in here who may not be a citizen of our
of our our state and denied instate
tuition at UNH because of that what are
we going to deal with those students
which we're going to have more and more
that come in that are not legal
residents of our country is that going
to be a problem if we start doing this
in the
schools well one of the requirements for
registration is that you show
documentation of
citizenship and you know right now the
allows for that requirement to be
established by signing a qualified voter
affidavit and as long as the supervisor
of the checklist has no reason to
believe that that information is not
true uh then it would be
accepted um if there is information that
is provided that uh to the contrary then
the supervisors when they're making that
decision have to make a determination is
it more likely than not that this person
is United States citizen and using that
standard would decide whether to approve
the name or not it is a crime for
somebody to uh register to vote who is
not properly qualified and so if there's
somebody that lies on their uh on their
voter registration form that says that
they are United States citizen when they
are not that that's is punishable thank
you any further questions from the
committee well we want to thank you very
much for coming today and informing us
about this
too okay what we're going to do is we're
again no we we've agreed to go back back
caucus
e
okay we're going to go ahead and try to
knock off several bills here before
lunch so the first bill which we're
going to be taking up is
1093 this is prohibiting mandatory Mass
policies
um
and uh I'll open up with some discussion
first
here uh Miss Ryan did you have something
you wanted to communicate to us on this
particular
bill
so okay thank you Mr chair um my name is
Mora Ryan and um I'm a member of the
state advisory committee for Education
I'm not here on behalf of them I'm here
on behalf of myself um but I did speak
with the chair who was not able to come
here today and what she wanted me to
communicate to you and she wrote a
letter to this effect um when the state
advisory committee wrote um our
recommendation regarding this particular
bill um
we used the phraseology that um we
opposed it as written because we thought
there should be an exception for
students who needed to wear a mask if it
was necessary and if it was in their IEP
um examples I I would 100% say that
that's something that's probably rare um
but examples would be if a student had a
transplant or if they had cystic
fibrosis or something like that where
they would need to wear a mask because
they'd be in an immuno compromised
position so in that case they would need
to wear a mask and it would be something
that would be a medical reason and we
just wanted to make sure that if there
were an exception like that that that
could be addressed obviously on the flip
side um with covid and masking um kids
with disabilities were not able to get
appropriate speech services and that is
a reason why it you know it's sort of
hard to have an you know absolute
because there should be some
exceptions thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee yes
representative Cornell so thank you for
taking my question so if it's in the
students IEP that that student with the
medical condition should only be around
other students who are also masks for
his
health what do you think about that so
you're asking me just I'm just going to
reiterate your question to make sure I
understand it if a student needs to be
in an environment where other people are
masked you're asking me what I'm I'm not
certain if you're asking me a medical
opinion so I just wanted to clarify that
I'm just saying if if it happens to end
up in the students IEP that their their
health is fragile and that other
students should be masked to be in
contact with that student you know what
would happen then if there's a mask
Prohibition in the in the school okay
um again I would say that that's usually
a pretty rare circumstance and it would
usually be only in the you know a
situation where a transplant is taking
place and it's usually going to be a
transitory situation but I think it
would be something that the school would
be able to work out if it was in the IEP
you know I think that's something where
we we can have common sense and work
something like that
out further
questions not seeing any thank thank you
very much thank you I appreciate it so
with that we're on 1093 and I'm going to
look to uh rep representative Noble for
a motion
please I move out to pass on hb19 three
is there a second I second the motion
okay we have a uh a second made by
represent Cordell and and a motion made
by representative Noble representative
Noble would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chair
um I would like to take this time to uh
we have a motion on the floor to move
forward
0911 H made by representative Noble is
there a second second represent cordelli
makes the second represent Noble would
you speak to your uh amending
motion um thank you
um so um the first change um is moving
it out of the studies section which was
uh probably not an appropriate section
and into a new um section the other
change is to
um
um for it was for the sack what they had
um given feedback for which was um you
know creating an exception for children
with IEPs and
504s so that they would still be able to
uh require masks if that if that was in
their
plan thank you ref Cordell you care to
speak as a second nothing thank you is
there any further discussion on the
amendment which we're talking 0911
H
sure
for
so everybody had a chance to read
now okay so um with that we have a
motion Is there further discussion on
the
amendment not seeing a Madam clerk would
you please call the
role Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative
leus yes representative beler yes
representative d yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pno yes representative
celo yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no Representative
selig
no represent representative Luna no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no representative
Sullivan no representative Damon no
OTP forther discussion yeah Mr chair I
can start with speaking to that motion
um so I just want to say that the
governor's mask mandate Exempted K
through 12 students teachers and staff
um school boards created their own
mandates for
masking and parents um in a lot of cases
were not able to get exemptions for
their kids who suffered from asthma or
Autism anxiety developmental
issues um however if we were under the
governor's mask mandate for the schools
that would not have been an issue at all
um
I if you've read the The Mask mandate
from the
governor
um um number six under that a person who
declines to wear a mask or cloth face
covering because of a medical or
developmental issue or difficulty
breathing shall not be required to
produce documentation or other evidence
um verifying the condition so the kids
would have been covered under
that in late February of 22
um the governor had a press conference
and um said that schools are now
required to end their mask
mandates um and and he was asked several
times during that that press conference
uh for some clarity on whether school
districts can decide on their own to end
the mask mandates and he said no schools
really need to transition their policy
away from the mask mandates
and they they actually um cited um that
the districts would be viol in violation
of Ed 306 rules um having to do with
meeting the instructional needs of each
individual student and and promoting a
school environment that was conducive to
learning now I remember at the time for
myself that I thought that was kind of
odd because we didn't do that for the
previous two years
um there there was objection to to that
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association
um I have a quote from uh baric
Christina um in a article from nhpr and
and this was this was in regards to in
the violation of the Ed 306 rules and he
said we were caught off guard by the
announcement yesterday for the last two
years the governor and the the
commissioner have repeatedly stated that
the decision of whether or not a school
district would require masks within
their facility has always been up to the
local school
boards the authority to put mask
mandates in place lies with the school
boards not the state he
said and the authority does not
change so I just um you know the New
Hampshire school boards Association is
is opposed to this bill and I
I I am I don't really understand why
because um the school boards also you
know the kids went through a terrible
time um it also was not easy for for
school boards um so this bill kind of
takes that um off their plate If This
Were Ever to be an issue again and if
puts it back on the state um if there is
some kind of Public Health crisis then
that mandate is going to have to come
from the state it should not come from
our local school
districts so at that time um after that
press conference and the
um um my school district sent out an
email saying that we're not allowed to
require masks anymore and um that was
the end of it there was no having a
special meeting or voting to change
their policy it ended right
there but that was not the case in every
District so in another article
um from um musoma Valley Regional School
District is discussing ways to come into
compliance with the state and so this
was an NBC 5 article and the
superintendent at the time said our
board
is potentially going to need to look at
their mandate for masking again and
probably look at an emergency meeting
coming up within the next few days so we
can discuss it
again and she goes on to say as
administrators and teachers we're tired
of asking kids to continue pulling up
their masks and to explain to them
why it's just kind of a mask fatigue if
you will on the part part of the wearers
wearing um there in the hearing it was
brought up about um there were some mask
lawsuits across the state and I um
understand that some may think that
those were
frivolous um because they were citing um
child restraint
statutes you you have to understand that
parents were desperate and looking for
anything that they could grab on to to
make this stop because their children
harmed this bill is not
misguided it's taking the school boards
off the hook because they're not
qualified to be making these types of
decisions and that was admitted in the
that if the state wants a man dat like I
said it's up to the
state this bill is about learning from
mistakes of the past and prevention for
the
future there certainly wasn't intent to
cause harm but the mass mandates did
cause a lot of harm and parents tried to
sound the alarm Bell and nobody would
listen so for as long as I'm sitting
here as a parent who through that I am
going to do everything that I can to
make sure that this never happens again
thank you Mr chair thank you very much
representative
cordel thank you Mr
chair um so last week on the house floor
during the debate on the free speech
amendment this is related someone
mentioned that old adage about um I may
disagree with what you say but I'll
fight for your right to say it I see a
similarity here because you can still
think that masks are effective and that
that the kids should wear them but um I
think that um as you heard in my
testimony I know there's a few of you
here who weren't at the hearing but I
bought up a lot of medical evidence and
um you know including Dr fouchi himself
uh expressing
some lack of shity over the
effectiveness of masks but
um Reasonable Doubt is has definitely
been been
raised uh so the choice of to whether a
child should wear a mask to school or
uh so anyway to vote in favor of this
bill you don't have to agree with any of
the evidence I presented in the hearing
this bill would not take away the right
to wear masks all it does is and I'm
sorry to read but I have a lot to say
and I don't want to waste your time and
I don't want to forget anything all it
does is make sure that the rights of
parents who don't want their children to
wear masks are respected too and
exercising this right Will Do no harm to
mask
wearers what concerns me is this logical
Paradox if some people think that masks
are effective and they choose to wear
them or have their kids wear them why
are they so concerned about other people
not wearing them if masks work won't
those wearing them be protected from
those who aren't uh regarding there's
the local control
argument and um by taking this decision
away from the school school boards and I
I think it might have been
representative Phillips who brought up a
good point there is no more local of a
unit than the family this this bill
isn't mandating some kind of detailed
curriculum it is simply protecting the
rights of parents to make personal
choices for their own children there is
one thing I want to reread from all
those articles I brought up I think it
Bears repeating because it was an
article just from this past December
just three months ago The Archives of
disease in childhood it
concluded real world effectiveness of
child mask mandates has not been
demonstrated with high quality evidence
the current body of scientific data does
not support masking children for
protection against
covid-19 we fail to find any evidence of
benefit from masking children child mask
mandates fail a basic risk benefit
analysis recommending child masking is
unsupported by current scientific data
and inconsistent with accepted ethical
Norms so this is from a medical journal
um there's one other thing I I want to
add um in the conclusion to the article
it says in medicine new interventions
with unknown benefit but known or
potential risks cannot be ethically
recommended or enforced until absence of
harm is demonstrated an intervention
should only be employed after benefit
has been demonstrated there's been a lot
of Reasonable Doubt brought up and I
think from listening to the testimony
that harm has been done um aside from
the the young man um and the I believe
it was the New Hampshire school school
board lobbyist who opposed this bill
everyone else who spoke at the hearing
supported it and I think they were all
moms whose children suffered in one way
or
another especially mentally we we are
trying to figure out what is the cause
of our Mental Health crisis perhaps
could be a small part of
it and I'm one of those moms I had to
see my son go off to school every day
with a mask and he's the kind of kid who
just takes things pretty easily and it
didn't really seem to affect him but I
can certainly like I I it it made me
feel really sad that he had to
experience half of his high school
wearing something covering his
face moms have a sick sense about what's
harmful for their children we need to
respect parents like them and pass this
Bill thank you thank you very
much um so is there any pardon me we're
moving to the vote right now so Madame
clerk uh we are now um voting on the
primary motion which was OTP on the uh
mandatory Mass policies for 1093 should
we move to
PA okay was there a motion did I thought
we the amendment that was a 10 vote
right okay yeah so that was 1010 so now
we're on the main
motion everybody ready here okay Madam
clerk Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative vure yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative yes representative Miler
no representative Cornell no
Representative selig no representative
Luna no representative Heath no
representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no Representative
bbon no representative S no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 10 days motion represent Miler I sir
second second we have a motion made by
represent miler uh and second by
represent luno the motion is to itl uh
1093 further discussion from the maker
of the motion no from the
second Madam clerk would you please call
the role when you're
ready uh represent I'm sorry Vice
chairman cordelli no
oops Representative leus no
representative Belcher no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no Representative cortiella no
representative Terry no representative
Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative s yes representative Luna
yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
ten
ten okay hary
okay okay who who was making the motion
I think that the the motion was made by
represent Myer and second by
representative luno and representa Balon
you're going to be doing the report and
uh represent Noble you'll be doing the
report yes thank you very much we got
two more bills we're going to quickly do
before
lunchtime uh the next one is
hp450 that's establishing a commission
on higher education consolidation of
which we going to change that title and
I'm going to hand the gav over to
represent cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman and I call on chairman lad for
a motion I'll make a motion OTP I'll
second that second by representative
luno discussion we got to slow down a
little bit I'm good yeah we're good okay
1450 correct 1450 1450 yes uh yes and
being the maker of the motion I would
like to propose amendment 0964 H that's
the one we heard this morning earlier I
will second back second um further
discussion representative lad
no represent luno anything no we had a
very good discussion this morning on it
and I really appreciate the committee's
time to um to entertain that thank
you okay so the U motion is uh ought to
pass on Amendment
0964 uh and we're uh looking to the
clerk when she's ready
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative luus yes representative
Belcher no representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative cig yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
n uh thank you uh do we have further
motion yes I'd like to make a motion
that uh on 1450 otpa with Amendment
0964 second second by representative
luno any further discussion from the
commit no seeing none thank you um Madam
ready Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher no representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative pel yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative celik yes representative
Luna yes representative te yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative suin yes
representative Damon yes chairman left
n consent yes the consent is okay right
yeah okay yes okay so we we'll move
forward to the last one we're going to
do before launch here I want to thank
everybody for that 1450 vote that's
going to be that's an important one here
1608 uh look to representative Miler for
a
that okay uh further discussion from the
maker of the the motion yeah I I think
that the U this is a it's a good it's a
good bill but it needs further study and
I also know that there's a similar Bill
coming over from the Senate that will
give us a little more time uh to look at
this thank you Mr chair I concur what
committee okay not seeing any further
discussion or hearing any uh uh madam
clerk would you please call a rooll uh
motion is on 1608 and the motion is
interim study Vice chairman Celli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative celik yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Wok yes representative
Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative suan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes
280 okay thank you very much that will
go on consent yeah and I'll do the
report okay thank you and with that
we're going to be taking a break now and
we'll come back at one hour from now
that' be making a quarter after
one thank
you
tomorrow
e
for
okay welcome back everybody we're ready
to go ahead and continue executing today
the hope is we can get through these
bills
today and that will eliminate some
people from having to come down
tomorrow um Amen to that um although I
remind people that the Senate Ed is
meeting tomorrow and a number of our
bills are on their
calendar so the first bill we're going
to be taking up uh is
1382 this is a bill relative to special
education support for military connected
students and I'm going to hand the gavl
over to uh represent cordelli uh thank
you Mr chairman um and I call on
chairman lad for a motion yes I'd re I'd
like to recommend
OTP thank you is there a second second
second by represent Woodcock okay oh go
ahead go ahead uh comment discussion yes
I'd like to offer
Amendment 11
82 uh yeah
1382 1129 is the amendment number is
there a second second second Again by
representative
Woodcock uh discussion yes thank you
um as you recall this was a a a bill
that addressed the issue when a special
child education child that's of the uh
military uh support from famili DOD
schools transfers into your school has
to deal with the military compact that
if they have an IEP which they're
carrying with them their paperwork the
old we called it the old 2011 file now
it's probably all digitized and etc etc
but they bring that in then the
receiving School accepts that and moves
forward with education programming now
they look at the IEP and they see an IEP
they immediately contact the sending
school and those records are transferred
to them immediately by way of the uh
digital
capabilities if they find that this IEP
is current this IEP is also uh meeting
what they're observing in the school and
and they want to continue it other words
there's another year left on that IEP
the IEP is good they can go forward and
uh deliver services in accordance with
that IEP that's the way our legislation
in this state is written right now so
just because they're coming in new
doesn't mean you have to go through the
IEP development processes again within
30 days and go through all that again
which is already in that IEP that's
causing of course it's a financial uh
loss to the community to have to you
know get out gather all the people
associated with that I AP and services
so what this does the amendment does
eliminate sections one and
two um and which reflect you know that
when you're receiving you get comparable
Services that's already that's already
being done and we're already looking at
the IEPs and we have the responsibility
of updating it and if necessary or going
with it that's already being done what's
not being done is section uh three and
section three deals with um witness fees
incurred by parents who are members of
the Armed Forces shall and do process
hearings be reimbursed by the Department
of Education if the hearing officer
finds in favor of the parent doesn't
mean the local school district has to do
it it means the state has to as far as I
know in talking with people at the
department this has not happened at all
uh when military kids move into this
this state this state is really
supportive and we always have been and
so but this is put in there in case they
have a due process hearing the findings
come out in behalf of the of the the
parent the student then those costs of
uh Legal Services all are reimbursed by
the state to that family for those costs
that's the only thing this bill will now
eliminated uh thank you um represent
with very good uh any any comments from
questions uh seeing none um Madam clerk
we can vote on Amendment 1129 H Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
cor yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative s yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative s yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
n further motion yes I'd like to make a
motion uh otpa on 1382 with the
amendment we just
did representative Woodcock would you
like to Second this as well please thank
you you're welcome
otpa see none mattam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler representative Cornell yes
representative celik yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock representative Hall
yes representative Bon yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
yes okay thank you very much uh what we
have next is we do have two bills which
we have not had time to really caucus on
both caucuses haven't that's the 1298
definition of part-time teachers there
was an amended hand Amendment handed out
at noon time should be on your desk and
the other one uh the the Republican
caucus hasn't really engaged in HB 1014
I know some there may be represent R do
today
some okay so I think what this is it's
going to be a good opportunity for us to
take a second a couple minutes or so to
uh look at uh 1090 10 uh 1298 and 1014
and then come back right there was also
an amendment handed out for 1015 1014
1015 or 10:15 yeah okay yes so you might
be looking at that one as
well so three bills
10:15 1298 and
you
it
e
well yeah I mean one of the new
idea
e
we're back in executive session um just
a reminder to everybody when we're
introducing a a motion the person that's
going to be introducing the motion is
going to be the person that speaks to it
I'm not going to ask the person making
the second to do any speaking either so
it's just going to be one person each
side uh uh addressing you know and this
has been agreed upon by both caucuses so
uh that's uh where we're going to go so
the first one we're going to start off
with is um HB
1298 the definition definition of
part-time
teachers and I Look to representative
drive for a motion I make a motion of
about to
it unless somebody else wanted to Second
okay yeah should I take you and do why
don't you recognize me then yeah yeah I
would like to recognize U chairman lad
for uh discussion I'd like to uh
introduce two uh 129 8 uh Amendment Le
127h is there a second second second by
representative
Miler uh discussion yes
uh when you look at the amendment the
amendment replaces the entire
bill and the amendment has been crafted
in conjunction with some folks we've
worked over it with Doe um we're talking
about part-time teachers with adjunct
authorization now it's not certification
authorization and what we've recognized
from prior commission work that there
are certain positions depending upon
your District where there's teacher
shortages and it's critical that we have
somebody in that uh position that's uh
got the knowledge and content and the
qualifications to U address the subject
or the content being uh instructed the
initial bill which we had said this
individual could uh be part-time basis
for less than 30
hours when we look at 30 hours and you
divide five into it you're beyond the 5
and a half hours a day of instruction
which basically occur whether whether in
the grade schools whether you count
recess as instruction but I always did
it was my favorite subject
and so it's down to 20 hours right now
so this is a part-time position but even
more
importantly it's to address local and
Statewide teacher shortage content area
so it's the Local District that has to
make the decision whether they can find
somebody to teach this science class or
the the class which is where they have
the teacher shortage area
within this bill on this amendment vers
what we initially had produced to
requires a bachelor's degree or hire
with a major in or related to the field
of
authorization other words if you're
coming in as a history teacher if there
is a shortage in history the person
would have to have a background a degree
in history you don't necessarily need
that teacher's ticket the certification
but you have the bachelor's degree in
history or uh and in and uh and must
submit passing scores on the content
knowledge exam or exams required for
authorization uh authorization area if
one exists there may be some subject
areas in talking with the director over
the doe they don't have exams for and
but if there is an exam for example of
History you'd have to you know pass that
exam uh uh verification of 5 years
occupational experience in or related to
the content field for of the
authorization is uh and if the New
Hampshire Department of Education
determines that this requirement is not
met the individual and the employing
public school or District May apply to
the New Hampshire Department for a
determination as whether adequate op
occupational experience is documented to
justify the issuance of an adjunct
authorization criminal background check
is required and it needs to be required
the adject authorization issued in this
uh um uh uh let's see going on down a
little farther here
um if in fact you're looking to become a
teacher this is not going to be a step
towards you have to take the alternative
approved program or the teacher
certification preparation program to get
certification so U that's important also
um if you've been if you lost your job
as a result of something which shouldn't
happen or you know the criminal back
ground or uh areas which it's been
revoked you're ineligible for this so
another area of extreme
importance and and lastly uh we talked
about the code of uh of ethics and the
professional code of conduct part-time
teachers this applies to the part-time
teachers as well so they have there's no
question that you have to abide by that
so that's the nature of this uh it's
trying to address the issues that we
have attended to and heard so much about
teacher shortage but it's not going to
give full-time status and it's going to
require that you have a person has a
background in it and a bachelor's
degree in it so I won't speak any more
to it I think thank you any any further
comments Miler yes thank you uh the
original Bill we had major concerns
about um and I think that uh the lad
Amendment does address those concerns
and provides uh an entree to some issues
that were dealt with in the teacher
shortage Committee of which
representative lad and I were both on
and uh as a result of that uh we will be
supporting this uh uh Amendment thank
you very
much see no further comments um Madame
clerk um roll call for the amendment
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
elure yes representative Dy yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative celik yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative bbon yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
a um representative TR did you have a
motion um ought to pass with amendment I
move that this be ought to pass with
Amendment
second second by representative Miler
any further discussion seeing none Madam
clerk Vice chairman calei yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler representative Cornell
representative cig representative luno
representative Heath yes representative
wot yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
Sullivan yes representative Damon yes
20 consent yes
okay going on down this list
here uh we did 1382
1450 establishing a
commission no we did that we did that
one also great uh
1452 credentials for superintendent and
business
officer recognized represent dve for a
1452 respecting the office of clerk just
a minute
okay
itl is there a second second so we have
motion on on the table itl on 1452 made
by representative dry and second by
represent cordelli representa
dry what I've seen is that statute is
kind of uh paints with broad stripes and
the the rules and regulations and
minutia belong in rules and regulations
and I think that this bill puts a very
long job description that belongs more
in rules and regulations into statute I
mean we had a bill recently that um
delineated job qualifications for the
commission of Education that only had
three short lines this is very long
extensive I mean it's good but it's but
it's too long to put into a statute I
think what we have here is a very good
model for local um districts to look at
superintendent further discussion no not
going to have it your sure just very
very quickly so I I agree with
representative dry not on the motion but
um but on the idea that these do belong
in rules unfortunately the Department of
Education took a different uh approach
to that eliminated rules for school
business officers and has um has uh
removed um much of the rules for um uh
for superintendent so uh so you know my
um you know what the what the State
Board of Education what a member of the
State Board of Education told me is well
if you really want to have um um
standards for school business officers
that handle over $3.4 billion doar a
year Statewide and you really want to
have standards for superintendents that
administer school districts that spend
$3.4 billion Statewide then you better
put it in law so um so when we get
around to uh to the OTP motion uh I will
be offering an amendment that um that uh
that does actually restore those uh
those those rules but but puts them into
law but uh I I do agree that they they
should just be in rules but
unfortunately aren't there anymore okay
we have a motion on table
1452 the motion is itl on credentials
for superintendent and superintendent
and business
officer and we've had uh for and against
already speaking so Madam Clerk when
you're ready 1452 the motion
itl Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative cellow yes
representative Terry yes representative
Myer no representative Cornell no
Representative celik no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no Representative
albone no representa Sullivan no
representative Damon no and chairman lad
yes 10 y 10
days I'd like to move F to pass is there
a second second we have a motion made by
representative luno second by
representative Miler uh and the motion
is OTP on 1452 representative luno thank
you very much Mr chair I'd like to offer
Amendment um 2024 05 35h it was handed
out maybe two or three weeks ago so I
don't know what everybody's availability
I do have a couple more copies if
there's anybody that really would like
to uh to to take a look at them but um I
did not make uh any uh additional copies
beyond what was already handed out to I
have one for the record I'll give you
mine it's 10 pages long yeah no I I can
I can hand it down I can okay represent
each
one going down
there oh you giving 5 five
05358 that's that's correct yeah I'd
like to move that second okay we have a
motion put forward to move 05 35h for
1452 made by represent luno and second
by represent Miler and and just very
quickly Mr chair um all 535 does is is
replace the um it replaces the entire
bill with what was um what was
originally the um uh the the rule the um
language that was in rules with with
regards to credentialing for school
business officers and uh and also with
regards to credentialing for
superintendent with very minor changes
suggested by the school administrator
Association on uh on the superintendent
rules further
discussion we have an amendment in front
of me any further discussion on 0535
H yes and Le
us I just wanted to say that Edna has
spent the last two years trying to
simplify all these things and having had
that taken out was in line with what
they're trying to do so putting it back
in either way is going opposite of what
do okay so we have a motion on the table
for o OTP a on this amendment not OTP
but uh uh yeah an OTP on the amendment
uh
0535 that's HB 1452 I'm okay with just
hands if you want to do that well let's
just take a roll call here um okay yes
go ahead Madam cler Vice chairman
cordelli yeah Representative leus no
representative Belcher no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Corell no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative s yes representative Luna
yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
no Tenny Ice T okay we have a motion on
the table OTP on
1452 who made
the I did representa Luna made the
original motion I'm assuming
representative Myer made the second we
go straight to okay no further
discussion scene okay Madam clerk when
you're ready Vice chairman M cardelli
yeah representative leus yeah
Representative beler no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Corell no
representative Terry no representative
Miler representative Cornell
representative cig yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative senin yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
tenes dry repent dry you do the uh
itl
report okay sliding down the next bill
ready
1476 this is Charter School memorandums
of understanding and I Look to represent
cordelli for a
motion uh thank you I would move um
inter room study I'll second
it
me ask a question I the last time we
were talking about this um
representative cordelli got texts from
Melissa white saying that she had some
information to share with us about this
did we ever get
it about memorandum of
studies um yeah do you want me to speak
to it first or well if you if you want
to pull your motion at this time and and
then we can speak to it and then I we'll
come back to you I'll pull my second
second or I can I can address it or you
can address it right now either way
right
yes yeah we can do it right now yeah so
represent cordelli will address that
when he's also speaking towards his
motion of right inter study right so um
I think that there were uh questions
related to a hard and fast November 1st
uh date um uh did talk with uh director
white um and uh there have been inst
instances where the um charter school
has
not signed
theou for various
reasons and um the concern is and refus
to provide services until theou was
signed so the concern is that
um po it's possible that a um a charter
school would not sign an M
moou uh until this November 1st deadline
and in those instances no Services would
be provided to the child uh prior to
November 1st um so I I am putting
forward the interim study motion because
I think that there are uh clearly
problems you know with that happening um
that need to be looked at and resolved
and I don't think we can um uh resolve
it here today um and we just saw a a
special that AIT come out the end of
last week also um with uh even more
concerns and questions so um I would
like to um Advance the motion of interum
study so we can take a look at the whole
theou okay is there further discussion
I'll I'll speak against the interim
study and
say pardon
me I'll speak against the interim study
and use that as my uh you know support
for ought to pass if we get to that to
that point so so U Mr chair thank you um
um I you know offered the bill we
offered the bill
to move the um the date where school
districts and charter schools have to
enter into a memorandum of understanding
for essentially how and where and who
pays for what or how things get paid for
build uh for special education services
um provided to um
to IEP students who attend charter
schools and um by law the um the school
district of residence is responsible for
um uh for these services and uh the
school district of residence is
responsible for these Services whether
or not anou is in place at all because
as long as the IEP is in place the
services are provided there may be some
confusion between the school district
and the charter as to how they're going
to be paid for um or where they're going
to be performed but the student is
receiving the services that are
specified in their IP that's fed I'm not
an expert I believe that's federal law
um so I'm I'm sort of surprised that
that an expert at the department would
would suggest that students um would not
be receiving services but another reason
why I think the 111 the November 1st
date is not
only practical because it's not a date
that exists in the middle of the summer
when um although special uh special
education and student service directors
are you know are there yearround at at
public school districts but at Charter
Schools they may not have any any
staffing during the during the summer
months um a number of us learned on
Friday that the number of um of students
identified uh as special education
apparently changes between before the
October 1st um uh collection date and
after October 1st and in fact we learned
from the um
um from the Department of Education
Brian eaten administrative Bureau of
school finance that um that in fact this
past year uh prior to October 1st the uh
the department was um was only aware of
26334 students identified as special
education Statewide but after October
1st um they um they were aware of 30,000
965 students so so
4,631 students hadn't been identified um
or at least made aware of at the
Department of Education until um till
the October 1 collection so so for for
that reason in addition to the Practical
reason I think pushing this to a
November first date really makes a lot
of sense makes a lot of sense because
you've got Staffing and place and it
makes a lot of sense because the New
Hampshire Department of Education knows
the um knows all of the kids that are um
that are identified for special
education services so I'm hoping we can
defeat the interim study report um at
recommendation and uh so that we can
take up an not to pass thank
you all right so we've had speaking for
and against so Madam clerk we have a
motion on the table for our inter room
study
on 1476 would you please call the role
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leas yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative cor yellow yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative SEL no representative
Luna no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no Representative bbon no represent
suvan no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 y 10
days Mr chair I'd like to move on to
pass second we have a motion put forward
on 1476 OTP made by represent luno and
second by represent Miler represent luno
vote
am oh that's right I don't think there
is one that any further discussion on
that Madam clerk when you're ready Vice
chairman cordelli
no Representative leus no Representative
beler no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no Representative corello no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative s yes representative luno
yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
days I'll do the to
pass
okay okay next bill down is
yeah was passed out
yeah
yeah so you're see you're signed up to
make the motion and I'll I'll do the
a
yeah
[Music]
spe
okay we're we're dealing with uh
1552 I Look to represent C for a
motion uh thank you I would like to move
out to
it hand to gble over to you you want to
get a second first oh no I second it I
no you made the motion I second it it's
like Larry and mo up here trying to run
it's
e
I'd like to call on representative
lad okay I'd like to uh put forth
Amendment
1552 second thank you
okay you recognize me to speak yes
representative lad okay thank you very
much uh what this amendment does it it
eliminates that section 4 new
language which is already something we
can do in law and is being done it's in
it's in statute but it's also in Rule
and it keeps the first section it of the
change on this so sections the read
right there it just takes out section
four and section five become section
four which is the effective
date uh it's basically in compliance
with what we're getting back from the
director over the department and his
advice to us so I don't think there's
much need to speak further on
it anyone else wish to
comment okay Madam clerk whenever you're
ready we'll do the uh roll call on
0931 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble y representative
Pell yes representative cor yellow yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Cel yes representative
luno representative Heath yes represent
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 20 a Zer a
representa Cordell you recognized yes I
would like to move uh ought to pass with
Amendment 09
318 okay we have a motion on the table
to approve uh the HB
1552 with the amendment
31h
and Madam
clerk Vice chairman cardelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble y representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative selig yes representative
luno representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Boni yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20a Z
consent moving down here
um check on copies I think I have dra
okay we're going to just take a short
break to get some copies here out of the
drawer in here in the office
per
me oh yeah take take a break here so is
the
plan
okay we're going to move on with uh HB
1616 this is a parental consent for
student participation in the Medicaid to
schools
and recognize representative cordelli
for a
motion
yes oh yeah she yeah we're gonna thank
you very much oh also if there were but
if there were some bills at the end
where it's not controversial yeah and I
could go yeah yeah yeah but don't plan
you know you don't need to accommodate
me if it just happens that way though
that probably will that one will be if
end
but you don't have to rearrange for me
earlier
send a
message
you
e
okay we're ready to go back now and and
deal with the next bill on the docket
that's HB 1616 relative parental consent
for student participation in the
Medicaid to schools program look to
representative cordelli for a motion uh
yes thank you I would like to move on to
second motion made by representa
cordelli second by representative beler
representa cordelli uh thank you I would
like to um offer uh an amendment uh for
passage uh and that amendment
is
H I got it right
here goes around which way your
go
two
amendment I think so oh
yeah okay well no no no no no he didn't
do that
theot put me I'll second it
okay
okay when you're re uh ready represent
cordelli uh thank you um we had quite a
hearing on this um with a number of
people testifying um basically uh just
requires uh parental consent uh to be
obtained with each new
service uh not just a one-time parental
consent um
what the amendment does um we had quite
a bit of discussion uh in relation to
Roman 9 lines 14 through 18 in relation
to violations being um contrary to the
code of conduct of violations of this
section of law being violations of the
code of conduct um the amendment removes
Roman
9 basally removes that uh penalty
possibility
further
amendment sure thank thank you Mr chair
um I I think the um the amendment
probably at least remove some um some
part of the bill that that is
particularly um uh
you know that particularly onerous but
so I'm probably I'm going to be
supporting the amendment but unlikely to
support the bill is amended thank you
very much okay uh mam Clark would you
please uh call the amendment the
amendment is
0716 that's to hb1
1616 Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative s yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
z okay we have a motion on the table now
that's been F put forward by represent
cordelli
discussion and you
ready represent Bon um I'm going to be
uh speaking against the bill um the
amendment makes it better but there's
still a lot of problems with it um one
of the problems is that uh there's a lot
of uh intricate details in here and we
had no nobody from the Department to
come to speak to to ask specific
questions as to actually how this would
work or what it means in addition uh we
recently
passed
um HB 1695 which requires school
districts to provide specific written
notification to parents each time
personal identific pii is transferred
from uh school districts to third party
which is um similar to what's being
requested here so I think there's a
little bit of an overlap in the bill but
primarily I think it's a complicated
Bill uh that we don't have a lot of
information on so I think it's premature
to uh to vote for it it would be better
suited as we talked about it in having a
subcommittee or inter interim study
thank
you okay uh F brother disc yes yeah
thank you Mr chair and um and I'm I'm I
I agree with what with what
representative balbon just said that
that perhaps this this does deserve
interim study and um and I'm sort of
also you know learning that that prior
to um you know a
a a
Medicaid or let me say it another way a
medical procedure performed under the
Medicaid to schools program that there'd
be a medical order that has to be signed
off first by by the parenter guardian
and and so the parenter guardian knows
what uh what services are being provided
um to their to their child in school and
um and it sort of renders I I think this
bill sort of you know
unnecessary
um thank you very much um representa
Cornell yes um I just looked up Medicaid
International classification of diseases
diagnostic code and I I I would want an
interim study or something because I
don't know what that has to do with the
services that are provided in school it
some looks like it has something to do
with World Health Organization and I
don't know what that has to do with
services that are provided in schools so
I think this is too confusing and I
can't vote for it represent
Bel thank you Mr chair I just want to
point out that I I think it is very
important that parental could s be
obtained before any any service um
because they can change over time what
schools are providing and just to read
real quick from the New Hampshire
Medicaid site on on the question and
answer Can a district provide services
without parent parental consent answer
yes a district can provide services
without parental
consent
representa
Damon thank you just to speak a little
further to representative Cornell's
remarks the international classification
of diseases ICD codes are diagnosis
codes they
specify what condition is being
addressed they're not service codes that
would be a service code or a procedure
procedure further discussion representor
McDonald thank you Mr chair so far the
discussion has focused around sections
eight and nine I'm drawing back
attention to section s it seems that the
report that we have gotten here as a
part of testimony from the Department of
Health and Human Services would also be
required to be sent to the chair of this
committee as well as the chair of Health
and Human services and both education
and Health Human Services in the Senate
as well and that would allow them to
delineate the information to all
committee members so that future
discussions surrounding Medicaid which
comes up in a lot of bills we can make
more informed decisions so if for no
other reason I would ask you to support
the bill for Section seven as
well okay any further discussion not
seeing any
hands need the motion though I don't
think there was an official making of
otpa yeah there was was there okay well
who was it motion um yeah who who did
make that
cordelli will make the motion vot
TPA yeah that's right it was okay
yeah okay Madam clerk would you please
call the
rooll vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
miler
no representative Cornell no
Representative celik no representative
Lun no representative Heath
Representative wock no representative
Hall no representative B bony
representative Sullivan no
representative Damon no shairon lad yes
10 10 motion yes represent myy move to
interim
study is there a second to interim study
made by represent Miler second represent
luno second Z represent miler
I think we've talked about this enough
thank you per
luno so um yeah I mean I think interim
study is where this belongs I think you
know there there's there's there's some
some clear inconsistencies with what the
terminology used in the bill I think
representative Damon brought that out um
and uh Medicaid to schools does does
come up uh uh quite a bit and I think we
have uh we had we we actually had some
significant impact on Medicaid the
schools during the uh during the covid
pandemic but again this is about billing
and um and the uh the procedures still
are subject to uh the medical orders
still subject to parental um approval so
um so I I you know I think interim
McDonald well I think that that's part
absolutely any further
discussion not say we're back to uh the
motion now of uh interim study for 16
16 Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli
yes Representative leus no
representative beler representative dry
no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no Representative corello no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative celik yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative bone yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
here repres Bon writing report
so
okay moving on
down uh 16
1882 relative to the Civics test
graduation
requirement I recognize representative
penel yes thank you I move a to pass on
House Bill 1682 is there a
second represent L seconds that
motion representative penno when you're
ready yes thank you I would like to put
2H is
second okay representative Lea seconds
the amendment put forth by
1162 if um go ahead I'm assuming you're
calling on me thank you um the amendment
makes first off this original bill was
put forth um as a request from the
Department of Education um my Amendment
changes line seven I struck out the
italicized and bolded sh score and left
it with the language that's already in
current
statute and the um Civics test is now is
digital and so
the sorry I can't read it my glasses
um if this just moves the um
accommodations over to RSA 193c as part
of the accommodations that are already a
that the department can already make
with the Statewide assessment test so it
rsas any further
amendment okay Madam clerk would you
please call the rule we have an
peternell 11
62h Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell
Representative cik no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no Representative baloni no
representative Sullivan no
representative Damon no chairman L yes
10 y 10
y okay the amendment fails we are back
to the main motion of
OTP on
1682 is it okay to call a CO a brief
can so we're going to caucus
uh for a little
R
e
okay we're back in executive session we
are looking at HB
and
uh representative Pell would you like to
withdraw your motion yes I'd like to
withdraw the ought to pass motion on
1682 and representative leus you made
the second would you withdraw that sure
would okay representative penel do you
have another motion bring forward yes I
would like to move interim study on
House Bill
1682 and okay so now we have motion of
interim study made by representative
Pell and second by representative Miler
uh the motion is interim study uh for
the Civics test graduation
requirement further discussion yes thank
you um we've had a little bit of
discussion about this bill and more is
needed and can be taken up as part of
the Civics curriculum study
commission further discussion well State
Madam clerk are you ready to call the
role Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative celik yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman l
yes
2080 any problem with consent no okay
thank
notion
yeah
since everybody realized we had 107
bills and we're on our second to last
now I shouldn't jinx us pardon
yes oh it's not the pen ultimate no I
want I love you I jined
myself that's right we got three more
bills including this one so 1014 is
relative to the registration of high
school students to vote represent
cordellia you recognize for a motion I
would move inter room study is there a
second me represent Lea seconds that so
representa cordelli we'd like to speak
to your motion uh thank you um I I think
there are still questions to be resolved
um related uh to this bill um you we we
heard from uh secretary scanland uh
today um but uh I I still have questions
even um after um hearing from the
secretary um in relation to um uh public
meetings in relation to um
um whether how things would work if
there is uh a Regional School District
and only certain um reg um super uh
supervisors of the checklist or town
clerks appear um and other students
being unable to register from that
school um that day I think uh causes a
problems um so I I I
think think this is already happening in
some places now so uh I think interim
study to look at the uh remaining
questions um is
appropriate further
discussion not seeing
any R Hall he didn't see I'm just
curious when he said it's already
happening the bill asks for school
boards to adopt a policy is that what's
already happening or you talking about
voter
registration in schools um I think that
um there might be voter registration but
certainly uh providing uh information on
happening further
discussion Madam
clerk repon H you to follow up no ask
for been the caucus has been
requested we will take a
caucus
isn't there another word rhymes with
caucus like
circus
I
e
have inter room study on the floor the
motion was made by represent celian
second by represent leus we had finished
the discussion gone forth with a request
for caucus so now we are at the point
where if there's no further discussion
on that we are ready for the that motion
to be
called inter room study is the call Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative beler yes yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Corell yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no Representative selig no
Representative luno no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative call no Representative
alboni no representative Sullivan no
representative Damon no and chairman lad
yes 10 y 10
days
for a motion
represent
H
H so we have a motion made by
representative Hall and second by
represent Miler OTP on 10:14 represent
Hall thank you Mr chair uh the intent of
this bipartisan bill is to require
school districts and private schools to
adopt policies to promote student um
voter registration it's about adopting
policies our American democracy is
strongest when all eligible citizens
participate and to do so they need to be
registered to vote and that is our
challenge in the grand of State for
young voters our schools play a critical
role in supporting and strengthening our
Democratic
Society even though New Hampshire at a
proud tradition of high to high voter
turnout the voter registration rate for
18y olds is a mere
15.6% or maybe a little higher as um
secretary scanland said but the bottom
line is it's slow and that said 83% of
registered New Hampshire 18y olds voted
in the 22 midterms so if they register
at 17 or 18 they're likely to vote a
major responsibility of a supervisor of
the checklist is to encourage voting as
we heard this morning so activities such
as coordinating a voter registration
Drive in a high school is one way to
encourage voting it's not mandated in
this bill it just suggests it's an
option um uh HB
1014 is a Way New Hampshire can increase
youth participation in elections by
requiring schools to adopt school
policies on voter education and
registration and I would like to end
with a quote from Jenna Karen from the
sunap high school by requiring school
districts and private high schools to
teach students about the registration
process and to provide assistance with
filing applications high school students
will be more exposed to Civic engagement
promoting a lifetime of political
engagement and thank you like to thank
you very
we any further discussion want put forth
an
amend repres
leus I I thought um what we heard today
was that we couldn't provide assistance
with filing the registration
applications I could answer
that said if everything is 101 then we
can choose yeah I'd like to recognize
represent cordelli oh you got a question
that
she thank you Mr chair the question was
I thought that they couldn't help right
now in law we actually have for special
ed if a student with disabilities
requires assistance to complete the
voter registration form a staff member
may be made available to help the
student complete the form so already
it's happening with some students it can
happen with some students and clearly
those are the two the two parts
informing students of the state
requirements of voter registration and
providing access to and assistance with
filing registration applications the
other thing if I could add one more
thing would be
um if you inform students if you if you
inform students in civics class some of
these kids are 14 years old 14y old
they're freshman they're taking Civics
they talk about voter registration that
is not going to translate into that kid
registering the vote you know maybe you
could have the town clerk come in and
talk about the process or whatever but
unless but it's totally different being
in a Civic class and this is a a a
separate activity but again this is
about adopting policy some schools do it
some schools don't some schools do this
some schools do that it's about adopting
policy so that everyone is on the same
page and
um that's the way it is per
cordelli uh thank you uh first I I think
what we just heard is defined as local
control um but secondly I would like to
offer an amendment if I could go
ahead I would like to offer
Amendment
second 1159 H it was handed out I think
at
lunchtime okay we have an amendment that
put forward and the Amendments been put
forward by representa cordelli and
second by representative Pell the
amendment number is 1159
copy okay representative cordelli would
like to speak to your
Amendment
uh thank you um during the hearing I I
believe we had um quite a bit of uh
discussion that um this really belonged
in the Civics uh
statutes uh so basically that's what
this amendment does it puts it um in um
18911 uh um under government and
Civics and um as you can see adds an F
which refers to existing law regarding
uh information on um
voting um and
that um I can just read the first
sentence or so to you um
18923 the State Board of Education is
hereby directed to distribute copies of
the State Constitution and election laws
to to all teachers of history and Civics
in the upper grades of elementary
schools and to teachers of United States
history and Junior and senior high
schools um to be used in instructing
their pupils relative to laws governing
elections and
voting um so I think this
um puts it in the proper section of
Statute and requires um information to
be available to students which is
basically I think what looking to have
done in our schools uh Rel related to
voting further discussion on that
Amendment representative
Hall I would just say that this
amendment totally misses the intent of
House Bill 1014 there's nothing about
develop adopting policy it's about
adding vote laws governing election and
voting in a Civic
Clause so thank you okay uh we've had
several people speak speak to it so now
we're going to have Madam clerk would
you rep luno yeah Mr chair thank you
um does does this amendment change
[Music]
the the statutory reference to
where I mean I I guess what I'm asking
bill yeah I mean we we've we've we'
germanness and even even making a a
reference I could go ahead I think the
original Bill amends 18911 and that's
the same section the statute that we're
in here this is
18953 oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry hang on I was looking at the wrong
18911 it adds an F under 18911 it
set well I just put the question out
there yeah I I you know I'm not the one
that determines to remain this that's up
to the speaker working with the the
clerk but I would say that from my
perspective we've we've modified things
18911 many times you know with Wellness
with uh lit financial literacy Etc move
it around within so I would say this is
train to the to the primary bill I I'll
I'll go with the chair's
um yeah rule on that so thank
you any further discussion Madam clerk
we have a motion on the table it's OTP
on a it's the adding the amendment 1159
H to
1014 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
Representative celik no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
representative W representative Hall no
representative bon no representative
Sullivan no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 y
10pr
okay we're back to the primary motion of
OTP on 1014 any further discussion
represent dry thank you I want to say I
do appreciate the distinction between
writing a policy and doing an action but
the problem with I have with this
version of the original bill is it says
policy shall include providing access to
an assistance with filing registration
applications
so when you are providing
access to one group over any other group
I think that that does not belong in
statute because uh we just discussed
this morning whether for example the
public was invited if you have a
registration at a high school and I
think that there are a lot of other
groups of people that would be
interested in this kind of um
accessibility uh however we're not
putting any of those into statute and I
don't want to concentrate on just one at
one
time represent
Damon with respect to the last
speaker we are not we're the education
committee we're working on educating our
students and this is an Endeavor to do
that on one of the most important
privileges of our Democratic civilized
society this isn't about prohibiting
anybody else from accessing registration
to vote should people choose to bring
that legislation forward next year I
would be happy to vote for
it further discussion representative pel
thank you um because of all of the
questions that we have about
discrimination and registering students
to vote in the high schools I think that
this is a topic that would be better
taken up by the election law committee
and put into statue with the election
law before the education committee
adopts a policy regarding um the
assistance of high school assisting high
school students in registering to
vote any further
discussion yes represent
Whit thank you chairman
um I would disagree with my associate
across the hall here um I think it's it
should be because this is going to Local
School boards to make their policy and
as you guys representative dve Point um
I understand what she's saying but
there's nothing that excludes the local
school board from saying under B that
you can't there will be non- accept for
special education allowed access so I
think those that's the whole point of
this it allows the school boys to make
legitimate policy for each community
that governs
registration
pres thank you Mr chair and for allowing
me to speak on this um speaking as a
parent of high school of a high school
student and a recent high school
graduate I think this bill is excellent
in terms of providing information to
students about how to do this this
doesn't say that it's going to provide
voter registration it says it'll provide
information about how to vote to
register to vote and that's a bipartisan
process that we should be encouraging
all of our students across the state
regardless of political idology or any
any other thing we want all of our
students engaged in the voting process
we also that way there's a much greater
likelihood they'll choose to continue to
stay voting in our state and stay
involved in our system which will mean
that we'll have more young people
choosing to stay in the state and grow
here representative uh H and then
represent Al thank you Mr chair just in
terms of discrimination I thought um
secretary scandin this morning spoke
rather clearly about discrimination and
that and how to handle it and it wasn't
a
luus well there was a comment made the
difference between um planning something
and doing something and where it's just
a
policy how many policies have we asked
schools to come up with that don't exist
um I much I much prefer the amendment
that we put on
that um actually does something thing
and gets the gets the information and
the instructions and everything out to
the
kids further discussion yes
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair and I concur with a lot of what
representative D said and I believe the
Secretary of State who spoke this
morning corroborated a lot of that I do
however think it is important to educate
our students on the voting process and
their obligations as Citizens and I'm in
a large part disappointed that's not
already occurring but I draw the line at
assisting them filing registering to
vote filing that form I go as far to say
that that's election interference and I
wish we could see a bipartisan
compromise as representative Cel noted
but nothing in the manner this bill was
brought forward has been bipartisan
we've had a few motions thus far and I
think we agreed that we want to study
this forward unfortunately that motion
failed we also just had mment to find a
bipartisan compromise that failed and I
think it's sad but because there has
been no compromise in the bill as is we
have stated several concerns and no one
seems to be willing to address them or
to support the Amendments both sides
we're not having that I cannot support
this bill as is so thank
you further discussion okay Madam clerk
role Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no Representative
beler no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
petel no Representative corello no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative cik definitely yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock
representative Hall yes representative B
Bon yes representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
ten
tenes
side
yeah we will talk about that because we
have some things we want to put in it
yeah okay
so we'll move on to the next
bill on my sheet it goes back to the top
and looking at
development
okay I Look to represent cordelli to
make a motion yes I'd like to move out
it okay okay representa cordelli thank
you um yeah I would like to uh move
119h I'll second
it could
I so we have a a motion made and put on
the table on amendment
119h made by representative cordelli and
lad
represent cordelli yes thank you um this
amendment um is a result of the uh
hearing that we had um with changes made
based on uh that um I'll just briefly
step through those the changes on the
first page on line 13 the screener and
training on the use of the screener is
added to that sentence
um will be performed um by the
department um over on page two in
several places we change age appropriate
to grade appropriate as was um on the
first page um and also as uh suggested
by uh representative ball in her
original
bill um over on page three on lines 15
and 16
the guid the uh department will provide
guidance to the districts uh on
instructional materials compliant with
evidence-based instruction by
September um and that uh comes prior to
their requirement on page one to
identify and
contract with a measurable
evidence-based uh Universal screener by
five
um it just
updates um in section 4 updates the
current uh RSA
259 um a dislexia and Related Disorders
uh screening
statute um new section is Section
Five
um my goal here with this bill is
comprehensive literacy um instruction
with a state average of 50 52%
proficient in um English in Reading um
we need we need to do things um in a in
a bold way and that includes uh the
screening the interventions the parental
involvement um it includes as we had in
here I'm looking of teacher preparation
programs where the the three New
Hampshire four New Hampshire
schools um that were surveyed by the
national teacher quality Council uh
three out of the four got D's or FS we
can't have that if we're going to bring
teachers into the system who are not
trained in the um
evidence-based um instructional methods
that are now recognized as helping
students to read going hand inand with
that we have many teachers who have been
in the system for a number of years who
maybe have not had that training the
Department of Education has gone through
um uh free training in the letters
program for over 3,000 people teachers
and parents in
State this new section section five
requires beginning in
2028 teachers getting uh certification
renewals and you can see um this um uh
seven or eight uh types of uh Educators
listed here that would have to undergo
um an assessment test uh to demonstrate
their ability to promote learning
through the evidence-based instructional
methods um I think that's very important
as well um and then the last section six
is an
appropriation um to be made by the
Department of
Finance um for this um to assist the
districts and also uh in um support of
the uh reading Improvement Grants that
are part of this bill um so you know
tried to cover many bases on this to put
forward an agenda to improve literacy um
in the state and I think we can't
isolate on just one section this year
and another section next year and
another section this year we have to
have a comprehensive plan for moving
forward and helping our kids learn to
read Because if we don't you know what
does it say for our future and our
future Workforce in this state so thank
discussion not seeing any hands on that
uh so we'll move forward and we have an
amendment in front of us Amendment
109h the motion is OTP on that amendment
to 1015 Madam clerk Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Belcher yes represent
resentative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Cel no
representative Luna no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no representative Sullivan no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
days representa
Boni um yes I'd like to uh to move um
Amendment uh Z
116h that was passed out last Wednesday
um from representative cascaden and
representative
ball okay we have a motion on the table
to put forward Amendment
116h for HB 1015 put forward by
representative bbon and second by
Bon thank you Mr chair um this amendment
was uh put together by excuse me I see
people looking does everybody have a
copy of that I don't think I
it anybody else need a copy right
now I think I at least for the record
Jen could we get a couple copies made
for this one right here I got a clean
else okay we'll take a five minute break
while that's being
done one6 right yes
yeah so we're just going to take a five
minute break if anybody wants to get up
and stretch
stretch can I ask a question yes um
it's my understanding that the
very
e
and represent Bon you had the floor
you'll get it right back so no just wait
here
for
ready to go ahead now uh represent
Bon okay um looking at the amendment um
on line five it changes the starting
date beginning July 1st
2027 um it includes a lot of the um in
section one um
it includes the ads chartered schools
which wasn't in the original um it
continues along with the uh same
language in section one and the changes
it deletes uh section two uh which uh
removes the specific directives
regarding tier 2 referrals and
interventions um this was a
collaborative effort between
representative ball and representative
cascaden and it keeps to the intent of
the original
bill um uh the five components of
reading is scientifically based reading
research by the national reading panel
University of Oregon and Washington
State all schools currently teach
reading and this amendment allows for
professional development materials and
teacher teacher preparation
programs uh uh there is no political
language roric or Playbook language nor
does does this bill promote any specific
Theory or program
um this would this bill would allow
individual districts to make uh their
own decisions on curriculum and
materials and uh um just stating more
that uh the passing this amendment to
the bill would provide continuity and
consistency in teaching
reading further discussion
representative of uh cordelli thank you
uh um just to follow on that um uh I
don't think the previous amendment that
we discussed um dictates any particular
curriculum it calls on the department to
provide to provide guidance to districts
on um instructional materials and um I'm
not sure what the reference to political
language was um but I don't believe
there was any political language um in
anything that I've proposed is
either brother disc represent miler
thank you Mr chair I'd like to thank uh
both representative cascaden and
representative ball for attempting to
bring bring this
bipartisan uh amendment to this
committee and I think they should
they've done a good job in trying to
work together uh as a Republican and a
Democrat and trying to address this
issue they should I thank them for doing
that further discussion representative
cordelli thank you I I
the the first sentence first few words
prevent pres prevent present a huge
problem to me we're kicking the can down
years um I'd also point out I'm
sorry in line seven um this um uh
provides um for all students through
grade five which I think um is not
necess either um uh I think it was Dr
Carol Tolman who was the co co-author of
the letters program um who said that um
in K through three we teach children to
re we uh teach children to read in
grades four and five they read to
learn I think that the emphasis needs to
be on grades uh K through
three um and if we Pro get them up to uh
proficiency levels in K grades K through
three we will be saving money um as um
local districts and as a state uh later
on further discussion representative
Terry you Mr chairman uh line three
specifies literacy skill development
with emphasis on literacy
literacy then if we come down to
line um lines five and
following and we picked this up at the
end of line six instruction in Literacy
for all students through grade five
including and now we have a
colon so all that
follows we come to
line
10 and the word mathematics is in
included and Mathematics reasoning and
Mathematics calculation including
fluency can someone um explain to me how
mathematics reasoning and Mathematics
calculation including fluency falls
development thank you representative Bon
that that actually was um in the
original that was presented um so it
wasn't
changed follow
yes
so so are you suggesting that because
it's there it should stay there even
there I believe when represent B was
here she explained the reasoning for
that um I don't have the you know exact
language that she used um but she felt
it was very important she talked about
um uh the the mathematics reasoning
which would have to be having to read to
understand the mathematics problems and
I believe she tied in uh the M the
mathematics fluency to
that further
discussion re SEL uh just just to
clarify as a former Elementary School
teacher um reading in mathematics skill
is very different than reading like a
story it's a different type of reading
skill and so fluency in it um is demon
at differently so learning to read word
problems for example or learning to read
even just the numbers across the page
and sequence is a specific skill that's
a different type of reading fluency than
reading words further discussion
representative McDonald Mr chair may
call a caucus please yes you may thank
you haven't had one in a
yeah
e
I
okay folks we're ready to head back into
the executing mode so we are in the
process of looking at Amendment
116h and that's to
hb10
one5
okay I'm going to ask the clerk right
now to call the role on one16 H are you
ready Madam clerk go ahead Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
Representative beler no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Coro no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative corn yes
representative s yes representative luno
yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative bbon yes
representative Selvin yes representative
Damon yes chairman lad no 10 y 10 NS
okay now we're back to the main motion
OTP any further discussion on the main
motion OTP for
10:15 who makes the motion you want me
to make the motion
yeah yes represent cell you're
recognized for a motion I'll move ought
to
pass that's already see we already have
that down there see that that was right
up here okay all right so so we're back
to the main motion right now yeah and
the motion is
OTP any further discussion not see any
further
discussion Madam clerk when you're
ready Vice chairman cardelli yes
representative lucus yes representative
belshire yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative SEL no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
representative wock representative Hall
no representative bon no representative
Sullivan no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 y 10 motion looking
motion so second to the motion of itl
represent luno makes second for itl on
10:15 and made by Ron
discussion not seeing any Madame clerk
would you please call the role
Vice chairman cordelli no Representative
leus no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
Corell no representative Terry no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative
selig yes representative luno yes
representative Heath yes representative
W representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative Sven yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 days 10
days chair yes just just to be clear um
uh I believe our position on this will
be an ought to pass is amended with
Amendment 1106 which is the ball
cascaden Amendment right that that's
right and and and our report will come
from representative belon okay okay and
of course the report from the other side
will be for the amendment forward by
represent
cordelli ought to
pass so we have two competing amendments
on the
up
session
you want to come in for that one
bill I gotta be here anyways
I'm well somebody on your team repres
wanted that representative
Cornell okay the next bill and last bill
is HP 1084 qualifications for the
commissioner of
Education we going to hand the gavel
over to represent
cordelli uh thank you um Mr chairman uh
this is House Bill
1184 relative to qualifications for the
commissioner of education and I call on
chairman
lad that is 1084 1084 I'm checking out
trying to find 1184
yeah
sorry okay I I uh made that motion for
itl on it I'd like to speak to my
second did we do that did we just did it
yeah it's getting
little you know it's tired here uh so uh
thank you very much um Mr chair I I'd
like to speak to the itl the itl for
this particular Bill uh dealing with
the uh qualifications for the commission
of Education I believe are strongly
should be those possessed by the
governor and
Council and in looking at this uh when
we're talking about having to have a
degree from the accredited college
University be certified as a teacher
have at least five years combined
experience in teaching or Administration
in a public school I look back over some
of the Commissioners and I did that
we've had Commissioners here that have
not had had these qualifications in
place and so I I I feel that it's we're
looking for a person that comes in with
the skill and knowledge to be able to
handle that and I'm not always convinced
that certification is the answer to that
um I look at uh the current commissioner
who is just recently appointed to the uh
Council for chief School administrators
in the country and there's got to be a
reason for that
um and you know and we've had other
Commissioners that you know I I go back
to the most recent commissioner prior to
the one we have and everybody brings in
their gifts and their qualifications and
it's based upon the school board making
that decision state board making that
decision with governor and councel and I
think the state's done a pretty good job
on of it so I would prefer to leave this
the way it is and to leave that respons
ility identifying the duties and the
responsibilities of course we do that
but in terms of what we're looking for
what's qualifying an individual take on
this responsibility leave it to the
executive branch thank
you uh the seconder would you like to
comment I I think
um no because there's yes I have
comments but okay U represent
SEL thank you and um so respectfully I
disagree I feel as though in order to
have someone who truly is excellent at
doing their job they need to have
experience they need to have training
they need to have firsthand knowledge of
what's happening I know that my own
growth as a teacher um and my
understanding of the different dynamics
that my students faced came over the
years that I had in the classroom from
understanding the challenges homeless
students had from understanding the
challenges students with disabilities
had and how to navigate all of the
different aspects of a school system
including how to use budgeting and how
to use resources came from having that
firsthand knowledge I think that someone
who's never had any experience within a
public school can't really speak to what
it's like in a public school can't speak
to what Public Schools needs and as this
role is really essentially the chief
executive for all public schools who
should be focused on supporting all
public schools they ought to have
experience and training relevant to
public
schools go further discussion
not seeing any further yes represent
cordelli uh I would just say um if we're
looking for a chief sorry thank you um
if we're looking for a chief executive
officer um I certainly would um be uh
more interested in um uh an experienced
business person um who understand
budgeting Etc um than um maybe someone
who had been a classroom teacher um who
did not have that kind of
experience further
discussion represent I I would just
counter that having budgeting experience
is excellent but it is only one very
small percentage of what's essential for
understanding how school systems work
further
leus people from the system are not
going to change the system and right now
given the
uh results that we're seeing our system
needs a change therefore we need a point
of view fresh from outside of the system
and the other part of that is we had a
parent talk about
how um the whole school was working to
deal with her autistic child they were
all trained in
education they did not were not able to
deal with her child's autism and yet
this same training which failed her son
is somehow going to help the
commissioner F further discussion not
seeing any Madam
clerk there vote yeah yeah Madam clerk
would you please call the rule the
motion on the floor is
itl vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Bel yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
peternell yes representative Corel yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative cig no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
representative wock representative Hall
no representative Alon no representative
Sullivan no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10
10 represent was represent Miler I'm
move to OTP is there a second repres
luno okay thank you represent luno
seconds representative Myers's motion
which is
OTP yeah I I will further discussion
yeah I will speak to this I I think it's
important I want to uh reiterate what
rake said we need somebody that
understands this and and believe me uh
if if the statement is that you don't
think that people who are in the system
can be Innovative you're absolutely
wrong uh prior I've been with uh several
uh commissioners of Education while I've
been on this committee
and frankly uh the former commissioner
for example Jenny Barry was very uh
Innovative in fact uh our state was a
model for every other state in the work
that she and Paul leather did so don't
tell me that uh incumbent Educators
aren't uh aren't creative and aren't uh
create aren't Innovative because they in
fact they are and I think the elements
that are in in this particular Bill do
site uh what the qualifications ought to
be and uh frankly I believe they're
missing at this point in time in our
commissioner further discussion
represent Luna thank you Mr chair I'd
afternoon
0976 H correct
9768 okay was there a second to this
amendment 0976 H okay so we have a
motion on the table for Amendment
09768 and that's for HB
1084 made by represent luno second by
represent Miler represent luno would
like to speak to your motion thank you
very much so so I'm off offering this um
this
amendment despite the um the
um audit report that was re released on
Friday by the uh uh uh legislative uh
budget office assistant that uh that
cites um um considerable
mismanagement in how the New Hampshire
Department of Education handles special
education um uh
uh
complaints and uh and it it cites um
mismanagement in how those complaints
were managed in the mismanagement in the
process despite that and despite this
morning's um um presentation by the uh
Commissioner of Education that uh ended
up obstructing access to documents
needed for the legislative budget
assistant office to carry out the statut
EFA audit despite all
that I'm offering this amendment that
will um push off the application of
House Bill 1084 only to appointments and
reappointments made after the effective
date of um of this U act so thank you
rson cordelli uh thank you I'm not sure
I I did not see the commissioner of
Education this morning I'm so I'm not
sure what uh is being referred to an
obstruction of providing
documents yeah so I'm happy so so
represent luno ween we won't be
recognized further discussion represent
luno sure thank you um and there is a um
it is archived on on YouTube but it's
the um joint legislative performance
audit and oversight committee which is
established under RSA 17- n colon1 and
they met this morning at 10:00 and my
understanding is it did run um into the
noon time hour and uh the commissioner
was both speaking to the um really the
scathing report that the
LBA uh had in their findings and um on
the um mismanagement of special
education uh um complaint processes but
also a basically saying that that the um
the department would refuse to cooperate
and refuse to allow access to um to
information that represent I want to
make clear that we're talking about
certification and requirements for that
we're not doing a review or audit of the
current situation no that's that's fine
Mr chair I was I was just um answering
representative cordell's question about
where where that information came from
further
discussion not seeing any uh we have a
motion on the floor it's relative uh to
the amendment 0976 h to
1084 the motion for that is to approve
that Amendment uh Madam clerk would you
please call the role Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Belcher no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Corell no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative
Cel yes representative Luna yes
representative Heath yes Representative
wock
no representative Hall
no Representative
bbon no representative Sullivan no
representative Damon
no chairman lad
no five y 15 days okay we're back to the
motion that's on could you could you
repeat that five five y I know it's
unusual um five y 15 names I that right
yes it's getting late and I just want to
make
sure okay we have a motion on the floor
1084 further discussion not see any
Madam
Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli no Representative
leus no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no Representative
coraya no representative Terry no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative celik yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative Sullivan yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
motion we had an it already we already
got we already got the it up there okay
so that wraps it up I'll do the um I'll
do9 that we'll have to check because
that that Amendment failed well they
always fail they fail 10 101 it's a
too yeah sure okay so so that's so we
are now done the bills which we have in
front of us for
this however there's going to be a brief
caucus for Republicans we have a
question
here yeah right now oh yeah we got a
question on 1014
aot is this ex s over Pard me is this
EXA this exact session is over we
concluded concluded all our work yeah
yeah